GOOD AFTERNOON I AM CALLING.
.
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
HEARING.
TO ORDER IS A SUB COMMITTEE
BECAUSE WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
QUORUM.
WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON FILE
TODAY THREE ARE ON CONSENT THE
CONSENT ITEMS ARE AS FOLLOWS I'D
NUMBER FOUR. AB TWENTY TO THIRTY
FIVE AYE QUIRK SILVA. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY EIGHT
DON'T TWENTY SIX BY MISS
FRIEDMAN.
I NUMBER NINE AB THIRTY TO
TWENTY THREE MISTER GRAYSON
THOSE ITEMS ARE ON CONSENT.
ON AT LEAST SIX BILLS TO BE
HEARD WILL BE TAKING TESTIMONY
FROM TWO WITNESSES.
AND SUPPORT TO WITNESSES
OPPOSITION OTHERS MAY LINE UP.
IN SUPPORTER OPPOSITION EACH
WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES IN
TWO MINUTES ONLY.
I'M SO PLEASE OF HAIR TO THAT
AND WE'LL GO AHEAD WITH THEIR
FIRST WHICH ARE FIRST AUTHORS
HERE TODAY.
AND THAT'S AYE MR MEDINA AND
THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY MR
MEDINA.
HERE.
YEAH IT'S ONLY KURT RUSSELL'S
FILE ITEM THREE
DIFFERENTIAL PAY DISTRICTS
RECEIVE NO LESS THAN FIFTY
PERCENT. OF HIS OR HER REGULAR
SALARY FOR THE DURATION OF THEIR
PARENTAL LEAVE.
A CHILD'S HEALTH AND WELL BEING
IS GREATLY AFFECTED BY THE
PRESENCE OR ABSENCE.
OF A CONSISTENT PARENT OR
CAREGIVER.
ESPECIALLY AT THE EARLIEST
STAGES OF DEVELOPMENT IN THE
FIRST TWELVE WEEKS.
AB TWENTY TWELVE ADDRESSES THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
IN CURRENT LAW.
HERE WITH ME TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE SOME OF THE BILL TWENTY
TWELVE IS BRIAN HA.
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND STEPHANIE DAWDLE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BRIAN HOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS. LIKE TO START MY
TESTIMONY BY REMINDING YOU ALL
THAT THIS IS THE TEACHER
APPRECIATION WEEK.
IT'S MY FAVORITE WE GET A YEAR.
WE ARE PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL WENT AB TWENTY THREE NINETY
THREE WAS ENACTED INTO LAW THERE
WAS AN OVERSIGHT. THAT PREVENT A
CERTAIN TYPE OF PART TIME
CLASSIFY STAFF FROM RECEIVING
ANY DIFFERENTIAL PAY.
THE INTENT.
OF.
.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY THREE
WHAT'S TO EXTEND THE
DIFFERENTIAL PAY BENEFIT.
TO THE REMAINING K. FOURTEEN
EMPLOYEES AB TWENTY TWELVE.
ADDRESSES THIS OVERSIGHT AS SUCH
WE URGE YOU.
SUPPORT THIS MINOR BUT VERY
IMPORTANT CHANGE AT ALL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS STEPHANIE AND
DOWDELL IN WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. WE ARE PROUD
CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WHICH.
WOULD IT CLOSE A LOOPHOLE AND
ENSURE THAT PART TIME FACULTY
ARE PROTECTED AND HAVE TO.
THE SAME.
RATES IS THE FULL TIME
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
SET BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION HAPPY DAY THE
TEACHER WEIRD YOUR SUPPORT.
OTHERS.
SEE NO OTHERS.
.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SAYING NO OPPOSITION OR ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
KNOWN OF QUESTIONS SO WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM AS OF YET.
ANYONE.
SO SO WE DON'T OF A QUORUM THE
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM. WILL GET A
MOTION ON THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AS A
TEACHER A RETIRED TEACHER THIRTY
FOUR YEARS.
ON THIS CALIFORNIA DAVIS
TEACHER I.
WILL TAKE.
RESPECTFULLY WHEN YOU DO HAVE A
QUORUM AS FREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYOR YOU.
THIRTY FOUR YEARS WHILE.
OUR THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER.
.
THREE SO WE'RE GONNA.
IS.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM PRESIDENT.
SEE HIM.
.
GONZALEZ.
AND MISS.
I DON'T I CAN'T READ THE LAST.
LOW MOAN.
YOU'VE DONE TO.
KILEY.
YOU HAVE ONE.
AREA MISTER CUNNINGHAM. GONE UP
CHIU CUNNINGHAM HAS.
.
VIOLENT NUMBER TO OR NO IT IS
NOT TO. FIRE THEM THEN THE
STATISTICALLY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE MISTER
CUNNINGHAM A. B..
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN
SIXTY.
PRETTY GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. UNDER
CURRENT LAW EDUCATION CODE FORTY
EIGHT NINE HUNDRED PROVIDES THAT
SEXUAL CYBERBULLYING CAN BE AN
OFFENSE WORTHY OF SCHOOL
SUSPENSION OR OTHER PUNISHMENT.
HOWEVER THERE'S NO PROVISION
CURRENT LAW.
THAT ALLOWS EDUCATION
TO REACH STUDENTS BEFORE THINGS
GET TO THAT STAGE.
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THE OPTION NOT A
MANDATE BUT AN OPTION.
CORPORATION AND.
EDUCATION INTO THE SEX ED
CURRICULUM THAT TEACHES KIDS
ABOUT THE LEGAL PHYSICAL
EMOTIONAL DANGERS OF SENDING
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT MESSAGES USING
THEIR PHONES.
OR OR ONLINE RESOURCES.
IT HAS A BROAD COALITION OF
SUPPORT.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PTA THE
NATIONAL RURAL EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION LAW ENFORCEMENT
GROUPS AND VICTIMS RIGHTS GROUPS.
AND.
WITH ME TODAY'S DJ PITTENGER
FROM THE SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
AND LASTLY I'D JUST SAY I WERE
SEEING A. NATIONAL MOVEMENT OF
SORTS WHICH IS FUELING A CULTURE
CHANGE ACROSS SOCIETY. OF THAT
IS MUCH NEEDED WITH RESPECT TO
APPROPRIATE CONDUCT.
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO GIVE
DISTRICTS THE OPTION OF
EDUCATING KIDS AT EARLY STAGE IN
THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
ABOUT OF APPROPRIATE. USES OF
THEIR PHONES AND OTHER MATERIALS.
AND I THINK IT'S A VALUABLE
MEASURE TO CONSIDER.
THANK THANK YOU.
JR ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT
SALAS OBISPO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
I URGE YOU TO LOOK CLOSELY AT
THIS INFORMATION. I WAS
INTRODUCED TO.
ASSEMBLYMAN CUNNINGHAM
REGARDING THIS TOPIC.
DUE TO A REAL CASE THAT WAS
OCCURRING IN ONE OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITHIN OUR COUNTY. WE
HAD YOUNG PEOPLE WHO. OUT THE
REQUEST OF ADULTS.
WORD TAKING PICTURES OF EACH
OTHER.
POSSESSED DOT.
IMAGE.
AND.
WERE NOT AWARE.
OF THE IMPLICATIONS OF THEM.
HAVING ACCESS AND
OBTAINING NOT A CHILD* OR.
WHAT IT MIGHT LEAD TO?
IN REGARDS TO THE THE VICTIM
THAT I THE IMAGE WAS TAKEN CARE
OF.
I'M IN MY YEARS OF EDUCATION I
HAVE COME ACROSS THIS SITUATION.
ON MANY OCCASIONS AND I THINK
THAT WE.
NEED TO PROVIDE OUR CHILDREN
WITH AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
EDUCATED REGARDING THEIR RISKS
REGARDING TECHNOLOGY USE IN THIS
AREA.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES ANY
OPPOSITION.
I WAS WAITING FOR THE GENTLEMAN
THE TABLE SPEAK GRANT MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROVIDERS OF STD PREVENTION AND.
AND TREATMENT SERVICES IN THE
STATE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
HE ANY ANY OPPOSITION.
AREA.
MY ANGER ON A SALE YOU OF
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THAT BELL. MAY
BELIEVE IT INJECTS UNNECESSARY
CONFUSION AND TO THE INSTRUCTION
ON THIS MATERIALS AND ADDS A.
OPTIONAL SECTION INTO A PROGRAM
THAT OTHERWISE HAS MANDATED
TOPICS OF INSTRUCTIONS. WE THINK
THE TERM SEXUALLY SUGGESTIVE AND
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT ARE VAGUE AND
OPEN TO INTERPRETATION WAYS THAT
DOESN'T REFLECT THE HEALTH THE
COULD BE. IN WAYS THAT DOESN'T
REFLECT THE HEALTH POSITIVE
FRAMEWORK OF OUR CURRENT
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL HEALTH
EDUCATION LAWS. I ALSO THINK IT
IS SUPERFLUOUS IN THE CURRENT
CONTEXT THE ANALYSIS. LAYS OUT
IN GREAT DETAIL HOW THIS
INFORMATION HAS BEEN PUT INTO
THE FRAMEWORK AT AGE APPROPRIATE
LEVELS. ALL THE WAY FROM
ELEMENTARY TO HIGH SCHOOL WITH
SPECIFIC INSTRUCTIONS AND.
EXERCISES ON THESE ISSUES AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU KNOW
VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
SEEN KNOW OPPOSITION ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SAYING NINE.
WE WILL WAIT.
INTO WE HAVE A QUORUM TO.
IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION LET ME
KNOW. I GO YES WELL QUICK
QUESTION.
BASED ON THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY PRESENTED DO YOU HAVE A
REAL.
RESPONSE OF THAT IN TERMS OF
WHETHER NOT THIS BILL IS LOOKING
AT ALL THE ELEMENTS THAT GO INTO
THIS.
HEALTHY KIDS ACT.
IN TERMS OF THE LEVELS OF
ENGAGEMENT AND SO FORTH AND SO
ON AND WHETHER NOT THIS FITS IN
IN SOME WAY.
YEAH I THINK THERE'S A
CONSERVATIVE DATA THE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT SOME OF IT THAT THIS
IS BECOMING A GROWING PROBLEM
AND THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE
THAT.
THAT CELL PHONES ARE BEING USED
USUALLY CELLPHONES BUT YOU'RE
ALSO ALSO COMPUTERS. ARE BEING
USED TO SHARE SESSION SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT PICTURES OF THE KIDS
SOMETIMES ADULTS ARE SOLICITING
KIDS FOR THAT SORT OF THING.
YEAH IT'S A GROWING TREND
THERE'S ONE PARTICULAR SURVEY
THAT.
SUGGESTED THAT FIFTEEN UP TO
FIFTEEN PERCENT OF KIDS HAVE.
AND GAUGE IN THIS KIND OF
CONDUCT TO THE EXTENT THAT'S
BEING ADDRESSED RIGHT NOW
THROUGH EXISTING.
CURRICULA I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT'S
AFFECTED THAN THEIR SOME
DISTRICTS THAT ARE TAKING THE
POSITION AND LOOKING AT WHAT.
CAN BE IN A COMPREHENSIVE SEX ED
PROGRAM IN AS IT'S OUTLINED IN
THE AT CO RIGHT NOW.
THAT THAT IN LEICESTER
SOMETHING THAT ALLOWS THEM TO.
INCORPORATE THIS IN THE
CURRICULUM.
THEY ARE FEELING LIKE THEY
CAN'T DO IT. AND WE SIMPLY MADE
OPTIONAL BECAUSE IF THIS IS A
PROBLEM IN A PARTICULAR SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
THEY DO THIS BILL WOULD GIVE
THEM THE OPTION TO INCORPORATE
THAT PARK.
.
YES DO SOME PREVENTION KIND OF
TRAINING AND THAT SORT OF THING.
WHERE THEY DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
THE OPTION AT LEAST A LOT OF
THEM DON'T BELIEVE THEY DO IF
THEY'RE NOT HAVING A PROBLEM THE
DISTRICT THEN?
WE CAN.
PROCEED WITH WHAT'S IN THEIR
EXISTING.
SEX ED CLASSES
WOULD THERE.
CURRICULUM PERSONS WHO DESIGNED
THE CURRICULUM BASICALLY BEING
ASKED TO DO THIS OR IS THIS JUST
SOMETHING WE SAYING YOU CAN DO
IT IF YOU FEEL LIKE DOING IT BUT.
IS IT BEING TAILORED SO THAT
THEY KNOW THAT IT SHOULD FIT
INTO THE REGULAR CURRICULUM.
JERRY MATCH I'M INTO THE CURRENT
CURRICULUM AS DESIGNED.
YOU I'M AUTHOR OF THE HEALTHY
KIDS AG BILL SO I AND I KNOW I
DIDN'T WRITE THE CREEK IN BUT I
KNOW HOW COMPLICATED AN
INTRICATE IT IS SO.
YOU WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHATEVER ADDITIONAL THINGS
COMING AND COMING AND IN A
CERTAIN WAY
SO THAT'S WHY I WAS WONDERING
WHETHER NOT.
THAT'S PART OF THIS MY MY INTENT
IS TO AUGMENT WHAT'S EXISTING
NOT. SUPPLEMENT OR RIGHT
SUPPLANT ANY OF IT BUT IF I. IF
I CAN IF I CAN ASK MY WITNESSES
RESPOND.
THAT'S EXACTLY ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I LIKED ABOUT THIS WHEN I
READ IT.
AS WE KNOW EDUCATION IS
COMPLICATED WE KEEP CRAMMING
MORE AND MORE AND MORE INTO OUR
DAY.
I SEE THIS FROM THE STANDPOINT
OF THAT DISTRICT FOLKS WHO ARE.
LOOKING AT THE CURRICULUM
DESIGNING THE COURSEWORK.
THE SCHOOL BOARDS IT JUST CALLS
THE ATTENTION TO OH YES THIS IS
A PLACE WHERE WE MIGHT WANT TO
MENTION THIS.
WITHIN WHAT WE ALREADY DO I
DON'T SEE THAT IT CHANGES
ANYTHING THAT WERE DOING. ITS
NOT GOING OUTSIDE OF ANY
GUIDELINES OF CURRICULUM OR WHAT
THIS LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS HAVE
ALREADY ADOPTED. IT JUST BECAUSE
THE ATTENTION TO THE FOLKS THAT.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
WE MIGHT WANT TO BRING THIS UP.
BRINGING THE TECHNOLOGY PIECE
INTO IT.
SO ARE WE ASKING FOR THE PERSONS
WHO ARE WE ASKING FOR A SPECIFIC
A CURRICULUM TO BE DEVELOPED.
THAT WOULD THEN BE GIVEN TO
SCHOOLS WHO MAY WANT TO
IMPLEMENT IT COULD CAN I CAN I
INTERJECT CHAIRMAN I MAY HAVE
SOME INFORMATION JUST UP TO HELP
YOU MAKE IT TO YOUR RIGHT. YOU
DID AUTHOR BILL AND THAT
FRAMEWORK THE DRAFT IS OUT. OKAY
SO THIS BILL ACTUALLY DOESN'T
TOUCH THAT FRAME OF THIS BILL
MERELY AUTHORIZES DISTRICTS.
TO.
TO TO.
I'M TO WRITE INSTRUCTIONS ON
THIS AND MAYBE THAT IS THIS BILL
MAKES IT WOULD THROUGH THE
PROCESS. AND THAT FREE MARKETS
PROVED STILL WON'T BE NECESSARY.
QUITE FRANKLY SO.
BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS
AN ISSUE DOESN'T HAVE A MIDDLE
SCHOOLER ON HERE AND STUFF.
RIGHT SO.
AND HIGH SCHOOLERS OUTSIDE THE
I KNOW THIS IS AN ISSUE I THINK
WHERE WE'RE GONNA END UP
POTENTIALLY IS.
THE FRAMEWORK.
WHAT LAST BEFORE THIS BILL GETS
TO THE PROCESS AND THAT WOULD?
WELL THAT'S WHAT I TRIED THAT
YET BUT I HOPE WOULD HAPPEN I
MEAN I'M NOT OPPOSED TO THE BILL
I THINK IT IS INFORMATION THAT'S
IMPORTANT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. YOU KNOW THAT WEEK
WITH THAT WE GIVE OUR SCHOOLS
AND AND LEADERSHIP THOUGH THOUGH
THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED TO
ACTUALLY MAKE IT FIT WITHIN IT
AND TO COMPLEMENT WHAT'S GOING
ON RATHER THAN JUST.
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHY I WAS ASKING
IS THIS CALLING FOR THEM TO DO
THAT TO DO THAT. THE WORK OF.
YOU KNOW MAKING SURE OR EITHER
CALLING FOR THE STATE. OF
SUPERINTENDED THE CRITICAL
COMMITTEE TO TO TO HAND OUT
SOMETHING THAT TO GIVE SOMETHING
TO THEM.
IT CURRENTLY. HAS NO MANDATE
ASPECT AND WE LOOKED AROUND FOR
SOMETHING WELL MAYBE THERE'S A
WAY THIS IS BEING DONE ALREADY
THAT WE CAN.
PUT INTO STATUTE AND.
QUITE FRANKLY I DIDN'T I DIDN'T
FIND ANYTHING THAT AYE. AYE
THOUGHTS OF LEASE IT RATHER OPEN
BUT I MEAN YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO MAKING SURE THIS
IS.
IF THE BILL MOST FOR THAT IT'S
INTEGRATED INTO THOUGH THE
LARGER SCHEME OKAY THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS.
WHEN WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
O'DONNELL HERE O'DONNELL HERE
KILEY HERE KILEY HILL HERE KALRA.
MCCARTY STEINORTH THURMOND
THURMOND HERE WEBER HERE WEBER
HERE OKAY CORN HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED I'M GOING TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BUT
THANK YOU OKAY AND THE MOTION IS
A DO PASS.
AGAIN THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY AND SECONDED UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL O'DONNELL. AYE AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
KALRA. MCCARTY STEINORTH
THURMOND. THURMAN AYE WEBER AYE
WEBER AYE.
WITH THOSE FOUR VOTES IT IS OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
WHEN IT'S OBVIOUSLY MOAN AFTER
MOSTLY MON WILL HAVE AS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER IF SHE IS NOT GOING TO
BE HERE MADE YOUR STAFF'S HERE
AND SOMEBODY ELSE COULD PRESENT
THAT BUILT.
BECAUSE WE ARE RUNNING SHORT OF
BILLS HERE PRETTY SOON.
SO.
THEY WERE NOT WAITING.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO START OFF BY BEGINNING
AT S. BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN LEARN BEST
WHEN THEY HAVE A STABLE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS THE GOAL OF AB
THIRTY ONE FORTY NINE IS TO
PROVIDE CONTENT CONTINUITY OF
INSTRUCTION TO CHILDREN. WHOSE
TEACHERS ARE OUT ON LONG TERM
LEAVES FROM TALKING TO SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IF FROM THE
DISTRICT.
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE IT'S
CLEAR THE AVAILABLE PERMITS
THROUGH THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHING CREDENTIALING DO NOT
ADDRESS ALL CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
LEAD TO LONG TERM LEAVES.
FOR INSTANCE WHEN TEACHERS OF
RECORD DO NOT PLAN TO BE OUT OF
THE CLASSROOM FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME AND THEN FOR
WHATEVER REASON HAVE TO PRO LONG
THEIR LEAVE.
SCHOOL EMPLOYERS ARE OFTEN LEFT
WITH NO CHOICE BUT TO BRING IN
ANOTHER SUBSTITUTE TEACHER AFTER
THE TWENTY OR THIRTY DAY
STATUTORY LIMITS.
THIS DISRUPTS THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT AND IS NOT IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF STUDENTS.
I HOPE THAT THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING CONVENES
AND MEANINGFUL STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS AND MAKES THE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE I DESCRIBED AND ANY OTHERS
THAT COME ABOUT. THROUGH THE
PROCESS CURRENTLY ESTABLISH.
WITH ME TODAY IS EVEN CARILLO
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND GOT LOST MUCH HUDDLE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CARE MEMBERS PEOPLE.
THANK YOU SAKE MY COUNTRY WITH
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WE ARE CO SPONSOR
OF AB THIRTY ONE FORTY NINE.
NOW WE ALL SHARE THE SAME DESIRE
FOR OUR FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
THAT'S TO MAINTAIN CONTINUITY OF
INSTRUCTION. FOR PUTTING THE
MOST HIGHLY TRAINED TEACHER IN
EVERY CLASSROOM.
OUR GOAL WITH BABY THIRTY ONE
FORTY NINE WAS THE GIVE SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS THE ABILITY TO
PREVENT DATA DAY SUBSTITUTES
FROM CYCLING IN AND OUT OF
CLASSROOMS.
AND INSTEAD KEEP IN FRONT OF
STUDENTS SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS.
WHO HAVE PROVEN TRACK RECORDS?
ADDITIONALLY THE EXPECTATION WAS
THAT OUR MEMBERS WOULD PROVIDE
THESE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
SUBSTITUTES WITH ADDITIONAL
TRAINING AND SUPPORTS. TO
FURTHER THEIR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND PUT THEM ON THE
PATH TO BECOMING EITHER TIPS ALL
HOLDERS OR FULLY CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS.
WE WILL NOW FOCUS OUR ATTENTION
ON THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
PUBLIC ADVOCATES AND ALL OTHER.
STAKEHOLDERS TO BRING ABOUT
MEANINGFUL CHANGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. CALLS WHICH OTHER
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION I ASSOCIATE MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE. AND WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
EFFORTS TO.
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE CSP WILL.
BE INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS AT
THE
ET SEEMED. WE'VE OUR OUR WORK
TOWARDS.
POSSIBLY GETTING SOLUTION THAT
THAT CARD MEMBERS COULD USE A TO
ADDRESS THIS THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU I DIDN'T SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS ERIC LAX
ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
THE SCHOOL EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION.
SUPPORT.
MEMBERS MICHAEL HOLE SIZE THERE
ON BEHALF THE KERN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS OFFICE
WE JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAMONT FOR.
BEING AN ADVOCATE ON THIS ISSUE
WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT HER EFFORTS
I CAN ALSO THINK THE SAME ON
HERS.
THANK YOU ANDREA BALLING TO HAVE
FOR THE SAN JOSE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEFF BARKER RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS AND
SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS S. BELGER SEE WITH
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
HONOR WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT WE WILL RECOMMEND
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION. ON FIRE
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S BILL ANALYSIS AND WE
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN AGAIN IS
THAT ON SUBSTITUTE SHORT TERM
SUBSTITUTES ARE UNDER QUALIFIED
IN THERE OKAY FOR SHORT TERM.
DE COVERAGE BUT WHEN YOU'RE
HAVE A LONGER TERM ABSENCE FOR.
A TEACHER.
THAT INTRUDE TEACHER OF RECORD
HAS TO HAVE TRAINING IN SUPPORT
AND MENTORS AND WE WERE REALLY
CONCERNED WITH THE BILL AS
AMENDED MAY FIRST SAID IT WAIT.
ON JEOPARDIZE THE QUALITY OF
STUDENTS DIRECTION AND ALSO
WEEKEND THE SAFEGUARDS AT THE
COMMISSION HAS PUT IN FOR
CERTAIN OUT PERMITS PUT
PRIMARILY THE TEMPORARY PERMIT
FOR STATUTORY LEAVE SO THAT. SO
WE FEEL THAT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT WELL ADDRESS ARE
CONCERNED WE WILL ON RECOMMEND
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION AND WE
REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
EVERYBODY THE LEGISLATURE THE
COMMISSION AND STAKEHOLDERS. TO
TOWARDS THAT END THANK YOU
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION RATTLE
MASSARO WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES
AGAIN APPRECIATE AND THE
OPENNESS OF THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS I'M ON THIS ISSUE WITH
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WE REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION.
WE WERE VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT ANY
ATTEMPTS TO.
EVEN IF WE UNDERSTAND THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE AND THAT THE
FOLKS FEEL PRETTY STRAPPED TO TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS AN ADULT IN
FRONT OF STUDENTS AT THE SAME
TIME WE NEED TO BE VERY CAUTIOUS
ABOUT LOWERING OUR STANDARDS.
AND WE BELIEVE THE PROPER PLACE
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION IS OF
THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AN AGENCY VERY
WELL EQUIPPED TOGETHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND REALLY COME TO
THE BEST CONSENSUS FOR HOW TO
ADDRESS AN ISSUE WITH THE
MINIMAL IMPACT.
ON THE THE QUALIFIED EDUCATORS
IN FRONT OF OUR HIGHEST EIGHT
STUDENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I ANY OTHER OPPOSITION SEEN
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK.
ON THANK YOU MUSLIM OWNED.
I UNDERSTAND THIS IS AN ISSUE
WE JUST GOT TO BE CAREFUL HOW WE
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE I APPRECIATE
THAT WOULD TURN OVER TO THE
COMMISSION. AND I AM CONFIDENT
THEY WILL BE EXPEDITIOUS IN OUR
ESOS ADDRESS HOUSING A BILL BE
EXPEDITIOUS PUT.
THE TOSS REMEMBER THAT AND I'M.
IN UNPREPARED AND UNDERPREPARED
TEACHER LEADS TO AN UNHEARD
STOOD.
SO WE NEED TO BE VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT PUTTING UNTRAINED. UNDER
HER TEACHERS IN THE CLASSROOM
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME THAT'S
MY CONCERN LISTEN I I SUB OVER
THE PHONE AND I HAVE ONE IN THE
STATE TAUGHT SEVENTH GRADE
ALGEBRA. AND ONE DAY.
WHEN I WAS A CHALLENGE FOR ME I
CAN'T IMAGINE BEING ASSIGNED TO
THAT FOR SIXTY DAYS IN THE I
WOULD WANT US I WOULD WANT
SOMEONE WHO'S WHO'S TRAINED. WHO
HAS SOME CONTENT KNOWLEDGE FOR
SURE BUT ALSO JUST AS IMPORTANT
QUITE FRANK ESPECIALLY MIDDLE
MIDDLE SCHOOL CLASSROOM?
IS CLUSTER MANAGEMENT SKILLS
YOU'VE GOTTA UNDERSTAND THAT
SUBSTITUTES COMING THERE WITH
VIRTUALLY NO TRAINING. NO
TRAINING AND PUT THEM IN A CLASS
OF FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
CAN HAVE VERY NEGATIVE
THE RESULTS CAN CAN VERY MUCH
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS TO
PERFORMANCE THAT'S A CONVENE
THAT A VERY VALID CONCERN. I
THINK WE'VE HERE HEARD SOME
PRESENT TODAY JUST BECAUSE IT'S.
INCONVENIENT DOESN'T MEAN YOU
DON'T NEED TO TRAIN YOUR
SUBSTITUTES.
FACT I WOULD RECOMMEND IT SOME
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE A POOL
AMONG SUPPORT SUBSTITUTES OF
TRAIN SETS TO SCAN THAT CAN
PERFORM THOSE MORE LONG TERM.
SUBSTITUTE POSITIONS I THINK
THAT WOULD BE KIND OF WISE
POLICY FOR SOME SOME DISTRICTS
TO ADOPT. AND ALSO THAT AS THE
AS THE CDC WHOEVER LOOKS AT THIS.
THE STAKEHOLDERS ISSUE TO
DISCUSS A SUNSET DATE BECAUSE
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET TO HONOR WE
DON'T HAVE THAT TEACHER SHORT
AGREE RIGHT.
SO I'M WITH THAT.
THANK YOU.
ANY ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NINE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED.
AND SECOND IT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. O'DONNELL AYE AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KILEY AYE
KALRA THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED.
MCCARTY STEINORTH STEINORTH AYE
THURMOND THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
BECAUSE FAVORITISM THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
.
DO WE HAVE MISS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER HERE.
I DON'T SEE HER COULD WE CALLED
THEIR OFFICE.
AND IF THEY COULD BRING THAT
EVEN HER STATEMENT.
ID.
HAPPY TO PRESENTED IT NEEDED.
YOU KILEY ARE YOU READY.
OKAY MISTER CONDIT.
OF GOING TO CONSENT RIGHT NOW.
.
WHEN WE TURN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS AS FOLLOWS.
I'M OF FILE ITEM EVER FOR AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY FIVE OF US
QUIRK SILVA THE MOTIONS YOU PASS
AS AMENDED FUN NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY TWENTY TWENTY SIX BY THIS
FRIEDMAN MOTIONS YOU PASS AS
AMENDED. FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY THREE BY
MISTER GRAYSON MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED.
DO WE DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
THURMOND AYE WEBER WEBER AYE.
SO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS PASSED
WHAT IS THE VOTE ON THE.
IT HAS FIVE VOTES.
I DON'T.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND START WITH.
.
I WENT INTO A FIRE NUMBER SEVEN
TH A. B. THIRTY THREE ZERO EIGHT
SIX
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS OFFERED
BY THE COMMITTEE AND.
I THINK OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT A B.
THIRTY EIGHTY SIX.
NOW THIS IS SIMILAR IN CONCEPT
TO A BILL I PRESENT LAST YEAR IN
THAT IT GIVES SPECIFIED STUDENTS
A RIGHT TO A TRANSFER TO A
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS WILLING. AYE
TO ACCEPT THEM.
AT LAST YEAR'S HEARING AS SOME
MAY REMEMBER I MEMBERS THIS
COMMITTEE EXPRESSED CONCERN AND
THAT MY BILL MIGHT BE DISRUPTIVE
FOR DISTRICTS AS IN THEORY IT
COULD HAVE EXTENDED A RIGHT TO
TRANSFER TO AROUND. AYE SIXTY
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
SO IN RESPONSE TO THOSE CONCERNS
AYE THIS BILL COVERS A
SUBSTANTIALLY NARROWER
POPULATION OF STUDENTS A VERY
SMALL FRACTION OF THAT. AND IT'S
SPECIFICALLY AIMED AT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS.
HOMELESS
MIGRANTS
FOSTER AND BELIEVE YOU.
I AS A RESULT OF THE GROUPS WHO
OPPOSE LAST YEAR'S BILL ARE NOT
IN OPPOSITION HOWARD NOT FILED
ANY OPPOSITION TO THAT.
QUITE SIMPLY I AB THIRTY SIX
WOULD ALLOW HOMELESS MIGRANT
FOSTER AND BULLIED USED TO
TRANSFER TO A DIFFERENT SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE ONE THAT THEY BE
ASSIGNED TO BECAUSE OF WHERE
THEY LIVE.
NOW Y. THESE PARTICULAR STUDENTS
WHY HOMELESS MIGRANT FOSTER AND
BULLIED YOUTH.
BECAUSE THESE ARE THE MOST
TRANSIENT THE STUDENTS MOST
DEPRIVED OF THE STABILITY THAT
IS SO IMPORTANT TO ACADEMIC
SUCCESS.
THIS LACK OF EDUCATIONAL
STABILITY COMPOUNDS THE BURDENS
TRAUMAS AND CHALLENGES
THAT HOMELESS MIGRANT FOSTER AND
BELIEVE YOUTH OFTEN FACE.
AB THIRTY EIGHTY SIX WILL
PROVIDE A MUCH NEEDED A MEASURE
OF STABILITY. BY ALLOWING THESE
KIDS TO ENROLL AND REMAIN IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT BEST FITS
THEIR NEEDS.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO ENSURE THEY
CAN RECEIVE THE TRANSPORTATION
THEY NEED TO GET TO SCHOOL.
THE SAME PRINCIPLE BEHIND THIS
BILL THAT CERTAIN STUDENTS
SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT AYE TO
TRANSPORTERS BEEN BRACED TWICE
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
AB TWO SIX FIVE NINE WITH THE
COMMITTEE BILL THAT DID THE
EXACT SAME THING AS TODAY'S BILL.
FOR CHILDREN OF ACTIVE MILITARY
DUTY PARENTS
IN FACT TODAY'S BILL SIMPLY ADDS
TO THAT SECTION OF THE CODE I
NEXT TO CHILDREN OF ACTIVE
MILITARY PARENTS ARE THE
HOMELESS MIGRANT FOSTER. AND I
AND BULLIED YOUTH.
IN ADDITION AB AT TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN FROM CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL.
GRANTS THE SAME RIGHT TO
TRANSFER FOR STUDENTS WHOSE
PARENTS WORK IN A DIFFERENT
SCHOOL DISTRICT AS THE DISTRICT
WHERE THEY LIVE.
I HAVE SOME WITNESSES WITH ME
TODAY I TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL STARTING WITH BISHARA I
SHOT SOME OF YOU MAY REMEMBER
HER FROM LAST YEAR. AND A HALF
OBVIO OUT MARTIN EITHER BOTH.
PARENTS WILL BE BRIEFLY
INTRODUCED BY ASHLEY LOTS AND
HIGHS ARE FROM PARA REVOLUTION.
YOU GOT TO WITNESS IS TO BE TWO
MINUTES EACH.
SO SHOULD AWAY. AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS LAST ACTUALLY LOTS
AND HAZIRA WITH PARENT
REVOLUTION.
WE ARE A LOS ANGELES BASED
NONPROFIT THAT WORKS WITH
FAMILIES AND HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO
SECURE AN EXCELLENT PUBLIC
EDUCATION FOR THEIR CHILDREN. AT
MANY OF THE PARENTS IN OUR
NETWORK STRUGGLE TO FIND THE
BEST FITTING PUBLIC SCHOOL FOR
THEIR CHILDREN AND WHEN THEY AYE
I'D CONSIDER THAT THEY CONSIDER
EVERY AVAILABLE OPTION TO THEM.
AYE WHEN THEY CAN'T FIND A GOOD
FIT.
SCHOOL FROM AMONG THE SCHOOLS
IN THE DISTRICT WHERE THEY
RESIDE THEY OFTEN LOOK ACROSS
WILL DOWN OR DISTRICT BOUNDARIES
AND TO THE INTRODUCED PICKED
TRANSFER PROCESS OF APPARENT IN
OUR NETWORK HERE KEY SURE SHAW
WHO'S GONNA SHARE MORE ABOUT HER
EXPERIENCE WITH YOU.
YEAH SO MY NAME IS KEY STAR I
LIVE IN FLORENCE ON THE BORDER
BETWEEN LOS ANGELES AND TORRANCE.
SCHOOL DISTRICT I AM THE MOTHER
ONCE THOUGHT HE WAS TOO SHY TO
COME.
HOW ó AND I CURRENTLY WORK FOR
THE WOMEN IF IN THE CHILDREN
PROGRAM I'M WORKING ON MY DEGREE
I OWE CAMINO COLLEGE I'M HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY EIGHTY SIX PER FAMILY
WITH HOMELESS BOSS THEIR BULLY
INMIGRANTES SHOWS AND?
THE CHALLENGE OF OVERCOMING
THESE VARIOUS BECOME MUCH WORSE
WHEN PARENTS HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT THAT CHILD IS
IN THE SCHOOL THAT IS BEST FIT
FOR THEM. I HAVE EXPERIENCE
HOMELESS LIST AND I KNOW THAT IN
THAT SITUATION YOU DO EVERYTHING
YOU CAN TO KEEP YOUR CHILD A
SPADE WAS POSSIBLE.
I AFTER I GOT BACK ON MY FEET I
TRIED TO GIVE MY SON A PERMIT TO
TRANSFER INTO A SCHOOL IT'S
ANOTHER DISTRICT THAT OUT
THOUGHT WOULD BE A GREAT FIT FOR
HIM.
WHERE I HAD THIS SAFETY
CONCERNS? THAN A SCHOOL THAT I
WAS KNOWN FOR BUT THE PERMIT WAS
DENIED AFTER TWO YEARS I THINK
THAT'S REALLY APPEALED THE
DECISION. FOR.
DO THEY COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION HOWEVER.
WELL WE WENT BACK TO THIS
SCHOOL.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A SEAT FOR HIM
ANYMORE
SO.
NOW HE IS AT THE SCHOOL THAT I
DID NOT FEEL IS A GOOD FIT FOR
HIM.
PARENTS SHOULD HAVE OPTIONS SO
WE CAN SEND OUR CHILDREN TO
SCHOOL THAT MEETS THEIR NEEDS
ESPECIALLY THOSE CHILDREN WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED TRAUMA. WHEN MY
SON BE AND THEN THE CURRENT
SCHOOL HE'S THE AND NOW HE'S
BEING BULLIED.
I HOPE YOU VOTE YES ON A. B.
THIRTY EIGHTY SIX SO FAMILIES
CAN WORK ON THE CHALLENGES IN
THEIR LIVES WITHOUT HAVING TO
WORRY ABOUT UPROOTED THEIR
CHILDREN. ARE KEEPING THEIR
CHILDREN IN THE SCHOOL THAT IS
NOT MEETING THEIR KNEES THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SAVANNAH MEDINA I AM A MOTHER OF
FIVE BOYS. MILDEST SON HAS
AUTISM AND I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES.
I AM HERE TODAY TO SPEAK TO
SUPPORT A. B. THIRTY EIGHTY SIX.
I CURRENTLY WORK AS A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER AND ALSO PROVIDE
BEHAVIOR THERAPY FOR CHILDREN
WITH AUTISM.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THIRTY EIGHTY
SIX BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CHILDREN WITH
FAMILIES THAT ARE NAVIGATING
THROUGH CHALLENGING SITUATIONS.
AND.
COULD BE ABLE TO STAY OR STAY IN
OR SEEK OUT A PUBLIC SCHOOL THAT
FITS BEST NO MATTER WHICH.
DISTRICT THOSE SCHOOLS ARE AND.
HIGH KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
DEAL WITH AN UNSTABLE HOUSING
AND STRUGGLE WITH HOMELESSNESS.
IN TWENTY TWELVE FOLLOWING A
SERIES OF DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES I BECAME HOMELESS
MYSELF.
DURING THIS PERIOD WE MOVED
AROUND A LOT AND MY CHILDREN
REMOVED BETWEEN SCHOOLS WITHIN A
DISTRICT AS WELL AS SCHOOLS
ACROSS DISTRICT.
AT ONE POINT MY ELDEST WAS MOVED.
WAS ASSIGNED THREE DIFFERENCE US
SCHOOLS IN ONE WEEK.
THE SCHOOLS WERE ACROSS TOWN
AND I DO NOT HAVE A CAR.
EVENTUALLY I WAS ABLE TO ENROLL
MY CHILDREN IN A SCHOOL THAT. IS
MEETING THEIR NEEDS AND THIS
MEANS A LOT TO ME.
THEY ARE STABLE IN IN A HIGH
QUALITY M. A AND I HIGHEST
QUALITY SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT. I
DON'T HAVE TO NAVIGATE THROUGH
ANOTHER SYSTEM I AM THANKFUL FOR
THIS SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY
ACCEPTED MY CHILDREN WITH THEIR
DISABILITIES. AND THEY WERE ABLE
TO CREATE AND I WAS ABLE TO
CREATE. CONTINUITY AND MAINTAIN
A COMMUNITY BY HAVING A STABLE
EDUCATION ENVIRONMENT FOR THEM.
TRYING TO NAVIGATE HOMELESSNESS
AND OR FOSTER YOUTH THE FOSTER
YOU SYSTEM MEANS.
DOING THE BEST YOU CAN WITH THE
LIMITED OPTIONS AVAILABLE.
AND TRYING TO GET WHATEVER
RESOURCES ARE OFFERED FROM BIG
BUREAUCRACIES FOR MY CHILDREN.
BEING ABLE TO STAY IN SCHOOL A
BETTER FIT.
FOR THEM.
HAS CREATED A LOT OF STABILITY
FOR MY FAMILY EVEN WITH OTHER
PARTS OF OUR LIVES WERE VERY
CHAOTIC.
AB THREE SUMMARIZE.
AB THIRTY SIX WILL HELP TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES LIKE MINE.
HAVE A BETTER CHANCE PROVIDING
CONTINUITY FOR OUR CHILDREN
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
C. NORTHERN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIRMAN
BILL LUCY WITH THAT VOICE IN
SUPPORT.
GREAT THANK YOU
CAN LOS FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS
WITH SUPPORT.
SEEING NOSES OF WERE ANY
OPPOSITION SAYING OPPOSITION ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WISH TO
COMMENT.
THEM. NAMES CHAIR UMPIRE THE
AUTHOR.
OFFER PRE IN THIS BILL FOR LIKE
TO THANK BOTH WITNESSES WHO
WHICH SHARED YOUR ADVOCACY.
PERRANCE A PARTICULAR ONE A
WELCOME BACK AND THANK THE SHAW
WELFARE ADVOCACY IN YOUR
PERSISTENCE.
I GUESS IF YOU APPEAL AND YOU
DON'T GET WHAT YOU NEED CORETTA
BILL SO WELL DONE AND NOW I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE STUDYING
BUT I HOPE THAT YOU'LL CONSIDER.
ADVOCACY BECAUSE SAID I YOU
CERTAINLY HAVE HELPED TO.
RAISE A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
FOR SUPPORTING STUDENTS I I WAS
READING RECENTLY.
THAT THERE ARE SOME SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND HOMELESS STUDENTS.
IN LA UNIFIED ALLOW AND SO WE
KNOW THAT THROUGHOUT LA COUNTY
INTO OUT MANY COUNTIES IN OUR
STATE. THERE MANY POLITICAL
STUDENTS AND SO THANK YOU BOTH
FOR YOUR ADVOCACY
AT AND I'M HONORED TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY THINK
INITIAL.
GREAT THANK YOU BUT I THINK THAT
WE HAVE A MOTION ARE IN.
WE THE MOTION A SECOND MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I BET.
THE COLOR OF.
STEVE PASSES AMENDED O'DONNELL
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYEKALRA MCCARTY
STEINORTH AYE STEINORTH AYE
THURMOND THURMOND AYE WEBER
WEBER AYE.
THE OF THOSE OTHERS FIVE VOTES.
NO I THINK.
IF. I WERE MADE HER WAIT BUT YOU
CLEARLY.
THIS WAS ON THE.
SUCH A GOOD WEEK TO BE THE
LEGISLATURE.
ALL COMES TO A CRASHING AND SOON.
THERE WERE ON.
.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX IT'S AB THREE ZERO TWO TWO.
WELL IN OVER SIX.
GREAT GET AFTER MISS CHAIRED
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS A. B. THIRTY TWENTY
TWO WOULD ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO GRANT HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
DIPLOMAS TO A PERSON THAT IS
DEPORTED. DURING THEIR SENIOR
YEAR IN HIGH SCHOOL.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ESTIMATES THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS ATTEND CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS INCLUDING SOME
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOCTOR
RECIPIENTS.
DESPITE THEIR EFFORTS MANY OF
HOUSTON'S FACE UNCERTAINTY IN
THEIR FUTURES GIVEN THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION SKILLED UP
DEPORTATION EFFORTS.
THE STUDENT GETS DEPORTED
THEY'LL FACE JOB AN EDUCATIONAL
BARRIERS WITHOUT A PROPER
EDUCATIONAL CREDENTIAL
ESPECIALLY IF THEY DON'T SPEAK
THE LANGUAGE LANGUAGE BEING
SPANISH IF THEY'RE. THEY'VE
LIVED THEIR WHOLE LIFE HERE OR
HAVE ANY CONNECTION TO THEIR
COUNTRY OF ORIGIN. WE SHOULD NOT
STRIP STUDENTS FROM THEIR A
FUTURE AND.
JUST BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
DEPORTED WE SHOULD AWARD THEIR
HARD WORK AND DEDICATION.
AB THIRTY TWENTY WOULD HELP
YOUTH WHO MAY FACE DEPORTATION
BY ALLOWING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
GRANT THEM THIS DIPLOMA IF THEY
ARE IN GOOD ACADEMIC STANDING
AND ARE DEPORTED ANYTIME DURING
THEIR SENIOR YEAR. THIS WAS
MODELED AFTER LEGISLATION THAT
WAS PUT INTO A FACT DURING.
THE DRAFT IN THE VIETNAM WAR
AND SOMETHING THAT WE'VE DONE
FOR PREVIOUS GENERATIONS UNDER
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES
NONETHELESS. BUT SOMETHING THAT
SAYS YOU FELT. A GOOD CHUNK OF
YOUR EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENT AND
REALIZE THAT THERE'S NOT A WAY
TO GO BACK IN AND TO FILL THAT
WHERE YOU'RE GOING NOW. AND WE
THINK THAT THE STUDENTS DESERVE
DIGNITY AND RESPECT IN A CHANCE
TO SUCCEED IN LIFE REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS AND.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ALLOW US BUT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TOWARD EXTEND A
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. WOULD LIKE
TO THINK THE OUT THERE AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR HELP WITH THIS
BILL.
THE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ELOQUENTLY STATED ALL THE
REASONS WHY THE SUPERINTENDENT
EMBARKED ON THIS ISSUE. ARE
GIVEN THE OF.
FEDERAL CLIMATE WITH IMMIGRATION.
THE SUPERINTENDENT WANTED TO
WORK ON SETTING SOME PROTECTIONS
IN PLACE TO ALLOW THE STUDENTS.
.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION AND HAVE TOOLS TO.
EASE THEIR TRANSITION IN THE
UNFORTUNATE EVENT THAT THE
STUDENTS FIND THEMSELVES BEING
DEPORTED OUT TO ANOTHER COUNTRY.
AND WITH THAT.
WE WE RESPECT
YOUR SUPPORT AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU LETTERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RON RAP
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
TERRY SO MUCH AUTO WITH COMMON
SENSE KIDS ACTION SUPPORT.
CARLSBERG HAS I'M HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THAT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
CHARTER SCHOOLS THANK YOU.
AND YOU GET AUTUMN BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
CHRIS RESPONSE AN APERTURE LOW
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEREK CLINICS ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
HI TIFFANI PULLEYBLANK NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CHRIS COULD DIFFERING EARLY ON
OF AND WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
GOOD POLICY CENTER IN SUPPORT.
AMY MINUTES WITH THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ISABEL GARCIA BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT.
I JACKSON WAS SENDING UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SENIOR OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS
FROM ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
.
DON'T KNOW CONDO CONTRARY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED YOU MAY CLOSE.
I JUST RESPECT LAST NIGHT I
THINK IT'S GREAT THAT YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MOTIONS YOU PASS
AS AMENDED O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
KALRA MCCARTY STEINORTH AYE
STEINORTH AYE THURMOND THURMOND
AYE WEBER. WEBER HIGH.
THOSE FIVE VOTES IT IS OUT.
HE WILL NOT GO TO F. ISLAND
MEMBER TO AB TWO ZERO ONE ONE
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
LET'S LET US PROCEED.
DO WE HAVE HERE JUST.
GROUP TAKE A SEAT SIR.
DO YOU SEE.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSE AND IS VERY SIMPLE BELT
WITH A VERY LIMITED PURPOSE.
TO ASSURE THAT EDUCATIONAL
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE
BUILT WITH PUBLIC DOLLARS TO
HELP SOME OF OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS.
MILTON RELIANCE ON OUR VERY OWN
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S.
GUIDANCE
ARE NOT FORCED TO SHUT DOWN.
BECAUSE THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
COURT DECISIONS THAT OVERRODE
THE D'S INTERPRETATION.
OF ALL.
SO THE CDI GUIDANCE DEALT WITH
PUBLIC NON CLASSROOM THE SCHOOLS
AND SPECIFICALLY THOSE THAT
PROVIDE WHAT'S OFTEN CALLED
BLINDED WARNINGS SO PART OF THE
INSTRUCTIONS ON LINE OR POEM ON
THE WORKPLACE. AND PARTS IN A
BRICK AND MORTAR EDUCATIONAL
FACILITIES TODAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THESE.
BRICK AND MORTAR FACILITIES ARE
OFTEN CALLED RESEARCH SENATE
RESOURCE CENTER THAT THAT THAT
IS THE PHYSICAL SITES.
IT'S THESE RESOURCE CENTERS
THAT WERE THE SUBJECT OF THE CD
<c.green> GUIDANCE.</c>
THEY WERE THE SUBJECT OF THE
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN COURT
DECISION UNDER THE ANDERSON
DECISION.
THAT AMENDED THAT GUIDANCE
AND THE SUBJECT OF TODAY'S BILL.
SO WHAT THE DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
SAID.
AND IS TO THE OTHER TWO
GUIDANCE IS THE CALIFORNIA LAW
ALLOWSA NON CLASSROOM BASED
PUBLIC SCHOOL. DECIDE UP
RESOURCE CENTERS EITHER IN THE
COUNTY WHERE THE SCHOOLS
AUTHORIZED.
OR IN AN ADJACENT COUNTY
SO WHERE'S MY GRAPHIC.
BASICALLY ANYTHING THERE IF
THAT MIDDLE COUNTY WHICH IS
SHASTA EYES WHERE THE. SCHOOL
WAS AUTHORIZED YOU GET SENATOR
RESOURCE CENTER A ANYTHING
ANYWHERE AROUND THERE.
.
AND OUT HUNDREDS OF SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE SERVING TENS OF
THOUSANDS.
STUDENTS INVESTED PUBLIC FUNDS
IN RELIANCE ON THIS GUIDANCE IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE STUDENTS ACCESS
TO A FISCAL SITE TO MEET WITH
TEACHERS RECEIVE TUTORING. DO
HOMEWORK TAKE TASKS I RECEIVE
ESSENTIAL SPECULATION EDUCATION
SERVICES AND OTHER THINGS.
SO THEN IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. AN
APPELLATE COURT OVERRODE THE CD
YOU GUIDANCE
I THAT ALL OF THE SCHOOLS HAD
RELIED UPON.
AND WHAT THE COURT SAID AND THIS
ACTUALLY REVERSE THE DISTRICT
COURTS TO.
IS THAT THESE RESOURCE CENTERS
CAN BE SET UP AND COUNTIES
ADJACENT TO WHERE THE SCHOOL WAS
AUTHORIZED.
BUT CANNOT BE SET IN THE IS SET
UP IN THE COUNTY OF
AUTHORIZATION ITSELF IN A LESS
THE SET WITHIN THE GEOGRAPHICAL
BOUNDARIES.
OF ITS AUTHORIZING DISTRICT.
SO THIS MEANT MANY CASES AYE AYE
SCHOOL COULD OPERATE A FACILITY
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY BUT COULD
NOT OPERATE THE SAME FACILITY A
FEW MILES DOWN THE ROAD YOU GET
THE SORT OF DON'T AT THE FACT
THAT YOU SEE THERE. SO I YOU
KNOW THE AND WE'LL HEAR MORE
ABOUT THIS FROM ONE OF OUR
WITNESSES BUT YOU COULD SET UP A
RESOURCE FACILITY IN THE RED.
AND THE ORANGE BUT NOT IN THE
GREAT THAT LIES IN BETWEEN.
THIS DECISION REVERSED WHAT AS I
SAID WITH THE DISTRICT COURT
HELD AND ADOPTED A LITERALIST
INTERPRETATION. OF THE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
REJECTED EVEN BY ABOUT TEXTUAL
US LIKE JUSTICE SCALIA OR EAT
OUT BECAUSE EVEN TAX LIST WILL
ALLOW SOME FLEXIBILITY TO
CORRECT DRAFTING ERRORS AND
AVOID ABSURD RESULTS.
BUT RESULT WHAT RESULTED IN THIS
CASE WAS A RESULT OF THE
DISTRICT COURT CHARACTERIZED AS
ABSURD JUST LOOK AT THE GRAPHIC.
CLEARLY ABSURD IT DEFIED THE
CD'S INTERPRETATION OF THE
STATUTE AND COULD NOT POSSIBLY
HAVE BEEN WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDED.
AS A RESULT UNIVERISTY GO SPEAK
TO THE BILL.
THE BILL WHICH YOU WANT TO DO
HERE TODAY AND I DON'T ABOUT
COURT CASES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
SO SPEAK TO THE BILL PLEASE OKAY
I DON'T THINK WE'LL BE I AM
SPEAKING AS WELL.
WHAT WOULD YOU STATE ALREADY IS
ARGUABLE
SO WAS PLEASE SPEAK TO THE BILL?
OKAY I'LL CONTINUE SPEAKING TO
THE BILL AS A RESULT
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE RESOURCE THAT RESOURCE
CENTERS WITH THOUSANDS OF
EMPLOYEES. AND AROUND THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND PUBLIC SCHOOL
CHILDREN REACHING FROM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY TO MODOC COUNTY HAVE BEEN
PLACED IN LEGAL LIMBO.
TODAY'S BILL IS ONLY PURPOSE IS
TO ALLOW THOSE RESOURCE CENTERS
TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE FOR THE
LIMITED PURPOSE IS REQUIRED BY
THE STATE.
NOW
A QUICK WORD ABOUT THE THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS WHOSE
FUTURES DEPEND ON HOW YOU VOTE
TODAY.
MORE THAN SIXTY THREE PERCENT OF
THE STUDENTS ARE SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED AND
QUALIFY FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS AND MORE THAN FORTY
SIX PERCENT ARE LATINO OR
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
NINETY PERCENT OF THESE RESOURCE
CENTERS ARE USED TO DELIVER
SERVICES TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS.
MANY OF THE STUDENTS SERVED A
RISK OF DROPPING OUT OF SCHOOL
OR HAVE PREVIOUSLY DROPPED OUT
OF SCHOOL AND ARE LOOKING FOR AN
ALTERNATIVE METHOD TO FINISH
THEIR INITIATION.
MANY STUDENTS CHOOSE ARE A.
INTERSCOPE INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAM TO GET AS THEIR ONLY
MEANS TO OBTAIN A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA AND WORKPLACE SKILLS.
ESPECIALLY TRUE IN RURAL AREAS.
THE PEDAGOGICAL FUNK FOUNDATION
OF THE SCHOOLS RELIES ON THEIR
ABILITY TO PLACE FACILITIES AT
REASONABLE DISTANCES FOR THEIR
STUDENTS.
THOUGHTS THE INABILITY TO CREATE
ACCESSIBLE FACILITIES WILL MAKE
IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR MANY OF THEM
TO OPERATE EFFECTIVELY.
FURTHER IN THE ABSENCE OF
TODAY'S BELL MORE MAY BE FORCED
TO BECOME A VIRTUAL SCHOOLS AS
THE BRICK AND MORTAR COMPONENT
OF BLENDED LEARNING. WILL BE
ELIMINATED.
THE COMMITTEE HAS RAISED
CONCERNS
THIS BILL WELL SOMEHOW REMOVE
GEOGRAPHICAL RESTRICTIONS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY IN STATUTE.
AND ALLOW FOR RESOURCE CENTER IS
A POP UP ANYWHERE IN THE STATE.
I WANT TO BE UNEQUIVOCAL.
THAT IS NOT THE INTENT.
THIS BILL.
IN FACT.
THE BILL WAS NOT EVEN INTENDED
FOR RESERVE REVERSED THE COURT
DECISION.
ALL WE'RE LOOKING TO DO IS
GRANDFATHER IN THE EXISTING
RESOURCE CENTERS THAT WERE SET
UP IN RELIANCE ON THE CD
GUIDANCE.
SO THAT THESE FACILITIES ARE NOT
FORCED TO SHUT DOWN WITH ALL OF
THOSE STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES
LEFT IN THE LURCH.
TO THE EXTENT OF THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL DOES MORE
THAN THAT WHICH I DON'T BELIEVE
IT DOES.
I NONE THE LESS COMMIT TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
ITS FULL SATISFACTION.
TO MAKE IT PELLUCID LI CLEAR
THAT THE BILL ALLOWS FOR THE
CONTINUED OPERATION OF THE INNER
COUNTY OUT OF DISTRICT RESOURCE
CENTERS AFFECTED BY THE ANDERSON
DECISION. NOTHING MORE NOTHING
LESS
I ASKED YOU DON'T FORCE THE
CENTERS THE SHUTDOWN I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. JOINING ME TODAY IS
THAT CYNTHIA RACHEL SHE'S A
TEACHER ADMINISTRATOR FOR
INNOVATIVE EDUCATION MANAGEMENT
SCHOOLS AND I APRIL ANDERSON AND
HER SON AYE MICHAEL ANDERSON AS
WELL AND DIE INTRODUCING THEM
VERY BRIEFLY. I WILL BE JEFF
RICE.
ON BEHALF OF THE A PLUS
THANK YOU HAVE FOUR MINUTES FOR.
TWO WITNESSES.
THANK YOU JUST TO INTRODUCE
MYSELF I'M JEFF RICE FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE A PLUS
PERSONALIZED LEARNING NETWORK
ASSOCIATION AND THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON
THE SCOPE AND.
AND INTENT OF THIS BILL
SO I WANT TO TURN THIS OVER NOW
TO CYNTHIA RACHEL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AS MENTIONED I'M CYNTHIA RACHEL
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION SUPPORT
SERVICES AND MY SCHOOLS
REPRESENT SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
HERE BECAUSE OF THE RECENT
APPELLATE DECISION AND HOW IT
OVERTURNED THE FOURTEEN YEARS OF
PRECEDENTS REGARDING ON
CLASSROOM BASED. RESOURCE CENTER
LOCATIONS WITHIN AUTHORIZING
COUNTY OF A CHARTER SCHOOL.
AS NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER
SCHOOLS WE ARE ABLE TO SERVE
STUDENTS IN THE COUNTIES IN
WHICH THE CHARTER IS AUTHORIZED
AS WELL AS THE ADJACENT COUNTIES.
ADJACENT COUNTIES AS MENTIONED
THE APPELLATE DECISION CREATED
THIS DON'T AFFECT THAT YOU CAN
SEE ON THE VISUAL HERE IN THIS
CASE SHASTA COUNTY CONSERVE.
STUDENT SHASTA TRIP SECONDARY
HOME SCHOOL CONSERVE STUDENTS
AND LOCATE RESOURCE CENTER
FACILITIES IN THE RED AREA AND
THE ORANGE AREA. WHILE THEY CAN
SERVE BUT NOT LOCATE RESOURCE
CENTER IS LOCATED IN THE GRAY
AREA WITHIN SHASTA COUNTY. AB
TWENTY ELEVEN FIXES THIS PROBLEM
BY ALLOWING NON CLASSROOM THE
SCHOOLS TO LOCATE FACILITIES FOR
STATE MANDATED EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES IN THIS GRAY AREA.
FOR MY SCHOOL AND MANY SCHOOLS
IN THE STATE THE SITUATION IS
VERY DIRE ONE IN PARTICULAR SKY
MOUNTAIN CHARTER SCHOOL IS
AUTHORIZED IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY THIS COUNTY COVERS TWENTY
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES. WELL ARE
AUTHORIZING DISTRICT ONLY
ACCOUNTS FOR SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE SQUARE MILES CAN YOU
IMAGINE BEING EXPECTED TO DRIVE
UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILES EACH WAY TO RECEIVE
SPECIAL EDUCATION EARLY LINK
ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES ON A REGULAR BASIS.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THE APPELLATE DECISION HAS
FORCED MANY OF OUR STUDENTS TO
DO OR AS SCHOOLS TO MAKE IT MORE
FEASIBLE WE'VE BEEN FORCED TO
CONTRACT OUT FOR EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES OR THIRD PARTY
FACILITIES THAT ARE CLOSER TO
THE STUDENTS HOMES. WHICH HAS
RESULTED IN INCREASED COSTS AND
LESS CONTINUITY OF INSTRUCTION
FOR STUDENTS WITH THE GREATEST
NEED.
AB TWENTY ELEVEN PLEASE
SUMMARIZE SO THE OTHER WITNESSES
WILL STILL OF TIME. AB TWENTY
ELEVEN SEEKS TO PROVIDE ALL
STUDENTS WE SERVE WITH THE STATE
MANDATED SERVICES WITHIN A
REASONABLE DRIVING DISTANCE OF
THEIR HOME THINK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
I AM APRIL ANDERSON THIS MY SON
MICHAEL.
I WOULD JUST LIKE YOU GUYS TO
KNOW THAT IF IT WASN'T FOR ALL
APPROVED CHARTER SCHOOL. MY SON
WOULD NOT BE GRADUATING HIGH
SCHOOL IN NITRATE HE WAS BULLIED.
HIS IEP WAS NOT BEING MET.
I THEN ENROLLED IN AND OLIVE
GROVE HE HAS.
HIS IEP MET. ALL THE TIME HE HAS
A MAKE CELL HE WAS SIX WEEKS
BEHIND WHEN I ENROLLED HIM.
HE IS NOW AND CAUGHT UP ON ALL
OF HIS WORK HIS EXCELLED HE IS.
WORKED SO HARD IN FACT USE
GRADUATING A YEAR EARLY.
DUE TO THE FACT THAT HE IS ABLE
TO GOING WHENEVER HE NEEDS TO TO
GET THE HELP THAT HE NEEDS.
AND THE TEACHERS ARE FANTASTIC
AND THEY HAVE JUST HELPED HIM
BEYOND I NEVER THOUGHT HE WOULD.
EVER MAKE IT.
BECAUSE HE WOULD.
HAVE HEADACHES BELLY ACHES
BECAUSE PUBLIC SCHOOL WISHES TO
MUCH FOR HIM.
HE WASN'T ABLE TO PHYSICALLY DO
IT.
HE WOULD VOMIT EVERY MORNING TO
GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE IT WAS JUST
TOO MUCH.
NEWS COULDN'T DO IT.
AND I WAS GRADUATING A YEAR
EARLY.
THANK YOU.
ARE OTHERS IN SUPPORT
STATE YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY PLEASE.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
SITUATION IN SUPPORT.
READY AND.
THANK YOU.
BRADY ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
INSPIRED CHARTER SCHOOL THANK
YOU.
A STRONG SUPPORT.
BLAKE ANDERSON.
LAKE.
LIKE ANDERSON.
I THINK SO.
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AB ONE ISN'T PARENT OF THOSE AND
STRUCK SUPPORTER OF THIS BOOK
THINK A BETWEEN.
JASON SOBEL THE GATEWAY
COMMITTEE CHARTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SERGEI TERRIBLE SLAVIC AMERICAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DON WILSON PARENT COURT
APPOINTED SPECIAL ADVOCATE FOR
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY DEPENDENCY
COURTS IN STRONG FOR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND FOR STUDENTS OF
THIS GREAT STATE CALIFORNIA
LET'S GO.
LYNN HOWERTON GRANDPARENT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
LARA LEADS TO STATE BOARD
AUTHORIZED ALL APPROVED CHARTER
SCHOOL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CALVET O'HALLORAN WITH CHARTER
SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT CENTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
PAUL KEEPER PACIFIC CHARTER
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
JOHN GARCIA ADULT AMEND
SOLUTIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BRENDA INTO A GUN BEHALF OF AND
VOICE IN SUPPORT.
ARE YOU SEEING NO OTHER SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE ONE MORE.
WE QUICK.
BUT WAS IT FOR YOU. BREEDING
ANDERSON IS AWKWARD THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE.
WE GET CLEARED UP IN FRONT
THEY'RE GONNA COME AND SIT AT
THE DESK THERE
.
THANK YOU YOU MAY.
RECEIVE HONORING.
GOOD AFTERNOON CALL SPECIAL WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE OF
THIS MEASURE.
.
OUR DISTRICTS
HAVE HIGH.
THOUGHT THIS ISSUE IN THE IN THE
COURTS.
WE'VE HAD THE.
DECISION BY THE APPELLATE COURT.
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE LOCAL
CONTROL ISSUE OR CONCERN THAT
THESE FACILITIES AND UP IN
DISTRICTS WHERE. THOSE BOARDS
HAVE NOT HAD THE BILL EITHER BE
NOTIFIED OF THESE FACILITIES OR
HAD THE OPTION TO PROVE THEM.
WE. WOULD RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
WITH THE AUTHOR THAT.
WITHOUT APPROVING THIS BILL
THAT THEY WOULD LEAVE THESE TO
SORT THE CURRENT FACILITIES AND
LIMBO. THERE'S NO OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE.
I CHARTER SCHOOLS TO SEEK THE
APPROVAL OF THE DISTRICTS
I GOT THERE AT THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY LOCATED IN.
THAT GEOGRAPHIC RESTRICTIONS IN
STATUTE.
HAVE A PURPOSE.
THE PURPOSE IS TO.
ALLOW AUTHORIZES JAAP TEAM TO
PROVIDE. HOT RIGOROUS OVERSIGHT.
WITHOUT THE RESTRICTIONS THAT
SIDE. THAT THIS BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE.
THE.
IT WOULD MAKE IT VERY MUCH WOULD
BE MAKE IT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
FOR AUTHORIZES TO PROVIDE THE
ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT THAT.
AND THAT MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE HAVE SOUGHT TO.
EMPOWER.
AND WE COULD BE VERY DIFFICULT
FOR.
AND.
DOES AUTHORIZES ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING.
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
IDEA TO BE ABLE TO DO THE.
REQUIRED ANNUAL AND SPIN.
SITE VISIT THAT'S REQUIRED IN
STATUTE.
AND.
BETTER YET THE MULTIPLE SITE
VISITS AT A RECOMMENDED THAT
AUTHORIZES TO.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
MUST RESPECT THE POSIBLE AND.
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE THANK YOU OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SUB BRAMBLE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION RESPECT
WHEN OPPOSITION.
WELL WE DID CO SPONSOR A BILL
LAST YEAR SENATE BILL EIGHT OH
EIGHT. WHICH REQUIRED ALL
CHARTER SCHOOLS BE LOCATED
WITHIN THEIR AUTHORIZING
DISTRICT AND I NOTE IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT DOES SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT. THE BLURRED
LINES SOMETIMES THAT OCCUR
BETWEEN A SATELLITE CAMPUS IN
THE CHARTER SCHOOL ASIDE FROM
THE OVERSIGHT ISSUE THAT THE
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION RAISED
THREE MORE REASONS WHY. ALLOWING
THE CHARTER SCHOOL OUR SATELLITE
CAMPUS TO LOCATE OUTSIDE THE
DISTRICT IS BAD POLICY NUMBER
ONE. OUR CHARTER PETITIONS MUST
DEMONSTRATE INTEREST OF TEACHERS
STUDENTS FAMILIES WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED AND PETITION SIGNATURES
INDICATE THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE
INTERESTED MEANINGFULLY IN
EITHER TEACHING AT OR HAVING
THEIR CHILDREN ATTEND THE
PROPOSED SCHOOL SO IF YOU ALLOW.
A SATELLITE LOCATIONS TO POP OUT
WITHOUT SUBMITTING A NEW CHARTER
SCHOOL PETITION THAT CREATES THE
VERY REAL POSSIBILITY THAT THERE
IS NOT COMMUNITY SUPPORT FOR THE
SCHOOL. AND THAT THERE WILL BE
AN INABILITY TO HIRE QUALIFIED
TEACHERS NUMBER TWO. KIDS
OUTSIDE THE DISTRICT WILL RETURN
TO THE DISTRICT OF RESIDENTS OF
THE CHARTER SCHOOL CLOSES SO THE
DISTRICT OF RESIDENCE DOES HAVE
A STAKE. IN WHETHER STUDENTS ARE
LEARNING ANYTHING OR WHETHER
THEY WILL HAVE TO MAKE UP FOR
LOST YEAR OF MATH INSTRUCTION A
CHARTER WHO WANTS OPERATE IN
SOME OF THE DISTRICT SHOULD GO
TO THAT BOARD AND SEEK
AUTHORIZATION THE NUMBER THREE.
HOW PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANT IS
THE ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE?
?
LIST CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
RECENTLY DID A DEEP DIVE INTO
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN
IN A PROPERLY AUTHORIZED OUTSIDE
OF THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M
QUOTING FROM THE REPORT IT READS
QUOTE. BECAUSE THE RESIDENTS
NEAR THE LOCATION OF AN OUT OF
DISTRICT SCHOOL CANNOT VOTE FOR
AUTHORIZING DISTRICTS BOARD
MEMBERS A DISTRICT THAT
AUTHORIZES THAT OUT OF DISTRICT
SCHOOL. IS NOT ACCOUNTABILITY IS
NOT ACCOUNTABLE TO THE COMMUNITY
IN WHICH THE SCHOOL IS LOCATED
AND IN ADDITION TO DISTRICTS IN
WHICH THE OUT OF SCHOOL. OUT OF
DISTRICT SCHOOLS ARE LOCATED OR
HOST DISTRICTS DON'T HAVE THE
MEANS OF CHALLENGING THE SCHOOLS
AUTHORIZATIONS I DID.
SPEAK YESTERDAY WITH THE CHIEF
COUNSEL OF THE STATE BOARD OF ED
AND I NOTICED THAT THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED CD GUIDANCE IN THE
ANDERSON CASE AND GRANDFATHER
AND.
COUNCIL.
INFORM ME THAT THEY'VE GIVEN
FOLKS A FULL YEAR TO GET IN
COMPLIANCE WITH.
THIS CASE AND THAT THEY'RE
ENCOURAGED TO REACH OUT TO THEIR
DISTRICT WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED
AND SEEK AUTHORIZATION SO IT'S
BAD POLICY FRANKLY WE'RE GENOVA.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS STILL ARE
STRAND FLOORS CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRISTEN BROWN OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL YOUNG
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
I JACKSON WAS SENDING UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU WILL GO BEHIND NO
IGNORE THEIR OPPOSITION WILL
BRING BEHIND THE REAL HERE.
MISTER COLLIER Y.. TO MY
THOUGHTS ON THIS THIS.
WE HEAR TALK ABOUT THE DONOR
HOLE THAT THIS BILL DOES MUCH
MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
AND THAT MAY EVEN YOU KNOW IN
THE OPINION OF SOME BE THE TRUE
INTENT OF THE BILL.
NONE OF THE SCHOOLS HAVE ASKED
FOR A WAIVER INDICATING THEY'VE
COME INTO COMPLIANCE WITH THE
ANDERSON CASE THEY ARE IN
COMPLIANCE NOW.
.
AND THE STATE ALREADY HAS A
PROCESS.
THE LAW ALREADY PROVIDES A WAY
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS TO OPEN
RESOURCE
CENTERS WITHIN THE COUNTY OTHER
AUTHORIZING ENTITY. JUST SUBMIT
A PROPOSAL FOR A COUNTY WIDE
BENEFIT CHARTER.
SO THERE'S A PROCESS NOW UNDER
SHOULD BE A PROCESS SPEAK FOR
OVERSIGHT REASONS ALONE.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE MAIN
CONCERNS I HAVE WE START.
OPERATING SINGS IN FAR OFF.
YOU KNOW.
GEOGRAPHICAL AREAS IT'S THE LACK
OF OVERSIGHT AND OFF OFTEN
ACCOUNTABILITY TO BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT MANY OF THESE VIRTUAL
SCHOOLS THE ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
IS IS IS IS IS NOT AT ALL ABOVE
AVERAGE NOT AT ALL.
SO WHY.
TO DISRUPT ANYONE WISH TO
COMMENT ON THE.
OKAY DOT TALKING OPPORTUNITY FOR
A AROUND IT WOULD ASSIST COMMON
THANK YOU.
NUMBER ONE THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL IS NOT TO ADDRESS VIRTUAL
SCHOOLS AT ALL.
VIRTUAL SCHOOLS BY REGULATORY
DEFINITION.
OUR SCHOOLS THAT. OFFER IT LEAST
EIGHTY PERCENT OR MORE OF
INSTRUCTION ONLINE.
THEREFORE THEY HAVE NO NEED FOR
RESOURCE CENTER FACILITIES
BECAUSE ALL THEIR INSTRUCTION IS
TAKING PLACE ONLINE. WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OUR INDEPENDENT
STUDY?
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THAT IS A
ARE MANY TYPES OF INSTRUCTIONAL
MODELS PERSONALIZED LEARNING.
HOME SCHOOLING INDEPENDENT STUDY
HYBRID IN BLENDED MODELS ALL OF
WHICH INCORPORATE AND INTEGRATE
FACILITIES TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
CRITICAL EDUCATION SERVICES THAT
STUDENTS NEED.
SO THE IDEA THAT THIS IS TIED TO
VIRTUAL SCHOOLS. IS SIMPLY FALSE
IT IS NOT TIED TO VIRTUAL
SCHOOLS.
NUMBER TWO.
ENROLLMENT IN INDEPENDENT STUDY
CHARTER SCHOOLS IS ALLOWED
THROUGH INDEPENDENT STUDY
STATUTE AS FOLLOWS.
ALL NON CLASSROOM BASED
INDEPENDENT STUDY CHARTER
SCHOOLS MAY ENROLL STUDENTS WHO
RESIDE THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY IN
WHICH THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
AUTHORIZED.
AND IN ANY ADJACENT COUNTY TO
WHICH THE CHARTER SCHOOL IS
AUTHORIZED. BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THE SERVICES PROVIDED.
THROUGH THOSE INDEPENDENT STUDY
CHARTER SCHOOLS IT IS ESSENTIAL
BECAUSE OF THE BLENDED NATURE OF
OFFERING A COMBINATION OF
INDEPENDENT STUDY HOME SCHOOLING.
SITE CLASSES AND ONLINE CLASSES
AND TUTORING AND TEACHER
ASSISTANTS
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
FACILITIES WITHIN A REACHED
REASONABLE DISTANCE.
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES SUCH AS THE ONES THAT
WE PROPOSE IN THIS BILL WHICH
ARE LIMITED TO. TESTING AND
ASSESSMENT
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
SPECIAL NEEDS SERVICES
AN ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES. AND SCIENCE LABS FOR
YOU SEE AG COURSES
PERIOD. ALL THIS BILL IS DOING
IS PROVIDING REASONABLE ACCESS
FOR THE PUPILS WHO HAPPEN TO
LIVE IN THE COUNTY IN WHICH
THEIR AUTHOR THEIR CHARTER
SCHOOLS AUTHORIZED. BUT AT A
GREAT DISTANCE AWAY FROM THE
GEOGRAPHICAL BOUNDARIES OF THE
AUTHORIZING DISTRICT. BECAUSE
THESE CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
ALREADY AUTHORIZED TO BE ABLE TO
PLACE A RESOURCE CENTER IN AN
ADJACENT COUNTY.
THE IDEA THAT. LOCAL CONTROL IS
BEING VIOLATED BY BEING ABLE TO
PLACE A RESOURCE CENTER IN
COUNTY IS NOT RELEVANT AT ALL
GIVEN THE DISTANCE.
SO I BELIEVE THAT ANSWERS ALL OF
YOUR QUESTION.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I AGREE WITH
YOU BUT THANK YOU. THAT'S THE
FACT THE OPPOSITION WISH TO
COMMENT ON THAT AT ALL.
MISTER CHAIR I WOULD JUST SAY
IN TERMS OF THE DEFINITION OF
NON CLASSROOM BASED INSTRUCTION
VIRTUAL.
ONLINE INSTRUCTION IS INCLUDED
SO I'M NOT SURE WHY THERE'S A
CONVERSATION THAT THIS DOESN'T
INCLUDE ONLINE INSTRUCTION I
THINK IN GENERAL WHY. THE.
.
YOU KNOW ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
MAY THAT IS THEIRS AND IT
CERTAINLY FOR VIRTUAL CHARTERS.
HAS TO BE SOMEONE IS VERY SELF
MOTIVATED TO HAVE TO BE YOU KNOW
IT'S OUT OLYMPIANS OUT ACTOR.
YOU KNOW SOMEONE SOMETIME TO
SOCIALLY AWKWARD WHO WHO'S VERY
INDEPENDENT THEY CAN PERFORM
VERY WELL BUT BECAUSE AND TIMES
SOMETIMES HAS BEEN REALLY CAST A
BROAD NET ABOUT WHO CAN.
WHO IS A SOUGHT OUT TO PUT?
?
UTILIZE VIRTUAL CHARTERS
SOMETIMES IT MAY BE SOMEONE WHO
NEEDS MORE SUPPORT AND IS GONNA
GET LESS IN AN ONLINE
ENVIRONMENT AS A RESULT MAYBE
THEY'RE PLAYING VIDEO GAMES
INSTEAD OF DOING INSTRUCTION SO
THAT'S SOME OF WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING THEIR. IN THE DATA BUT
CERTAINLY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THIS IS. A FOUR NINE CLASS IN
BASS CHARTERS THAT WOULD INCLUDE.
VIRTUAL CHARTERS.
THANK YOU.
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AND SITTING NOT THAT I WANT TO
ASK A QUESTION BECAUSE NOW I'M
ALL I AM TO LOOK CONFUSED.
WHO TRYING TO CLARITY IF I LOOK
AT YOUR LITTLE MATH THAT'S THERE?
YOUR CONCERN IS THAT NOW THE RED
AREA I GUESS IS THAT AT COUNTY
WITHIN.
SOME AREA IS IS THAT THEY ARE OR
THAT I WAS THE DISTRICT
BOUNDARIES FOR THAT PARTICULAR
SPOKEN THAT'S DISTRICT BOUNDARY
FOR THAT SCHOOL OKAY. AND THAT'S
ALL IN SHASTA COUNTY YEAH SO
THAT'S.
YOUR CONCERN IS THAT.
YOU CAN PUT THESE
THOMAS CENTERS IN IN THE ORANGE
AREA ORANGE AND RED ONES IN RICH
BUT NOT THE GRAY BUT YOU CAN'T
PUT A CENTER IN SHASTA COUNTY IS
THAT THE CONCERNED YOU CAN'T PUT
A CENTER IN SHASTA COUNTY.
OUTSIDE THE READ IN THOSE GRAY
ERRORS LITTLE GRAY AREA YES
MA'AM AND THAT'S BECAUSE BECAUSE
OF THE APPELLATE COURT.
INTERPRETATION OF CURRENT
STATUTE.
OKAY
SO.
OKAY SO THAT THE SO YOU NOT CAN.
ACCORDING TO YOUR ARGUMENT YOU
NOT CONCERNED ABOUT THE REST OF
THE STATE YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PIECE OF.
THE LAND THAT'S WITHIN SHASTA
COUNTY CORRECT OKAY THAT'S NOT
VERY CLEAR FROM WHAT IS WRITTEN
HERE AND THAT'S WHY. I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND.
AND.
.
YEAH IT IT IT'S VERY CONFUSING
AS THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN SO AS I
TRY TO FIGURE OUT SO YOU REALLY
THE LITTLE AREA THERE YES WHEN
YOU'RE ASKING TO GRANDFATHER
THOSE AND THERE ARE CENTERS
ALREADY IN THOSE AREAS NOW IS
THAT THE ISSUE.
OKAY AND YOU ASKING AVOID LIMIT
RULING TO BASICALLY DEAL WITH
THE INSIDE OF SHASTA COUNTY.
OR ANY COUNTY IN WHICH A NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOL
IS AN EXISTING NON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTER SCHOOLS CURRENTLY
OPERATING AND HAS HAD RESOURCE
AND
IS THERE.
OUTSIDE OF THE DISTRICT
BOUNDARIES BUT WITHIN THE COUNTY.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY ARE THERE.
WE ASSUME THAT THERE ARE
SOMEWHERE.
BY TODAY'S STANDARDS SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN FIFTY AND A HUNDRED.
NOT THE HEART OF THE BILLS THIS.
I'M READING FROM THE BILL NON
CLASSROOM BASED.
DESTRUCTION
SHALL NOT BE SUBJECT TO THE
GEOGRAPHICAL RESTRICTIONS
SO THIS IS LIKE THE WILD WEST
ROOM OPENING THIS UP.
WELL THERE ARE ALREADY
RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE REGARDING
WHERE STUDENTS CAN BE ENROLLED
SO WE'RE ONLY TALKING ABOUT THE
COUNTY IN WHICH.
CHARTER SCHOOLS AUTHORIZED IN
ANY ADJACENT COUNTY THERE'S
ALREADY EXCEPT AN EXCEPTION IN
STATUTE THAT ALLOWS FOR RESOURCE
CENTERS TO BE LOCATED IN AN
ADJACENT COUNTY SO WE'RE ONLY
TALKING ABOUT THE COUNTY IN
WHICH.
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS AUTHORIZED
AND ONLY BE ON THE DISTRICT
BOUNDARIES AND TO THE CLOUD OF
THOSE LAWS YOU CITED DON'T APPLY
HERE.
WHAT LOWER RIVER IF I'M READING
THE BILL CORRECTLY? THE OTHER
LAWYER THE OTHER. THE OTHER
LAWYER DECIDED DOES NOT IS NOT
APPLICABLE.
REVISTA RATING THAT ESSENTIALLY.
MISTER CHAIR.
WELL NOT WITHSTANDING IS A KEY
WORD.
WE'RE ONLY TALKING ABOUT FORCE
AND SIX OH FIVE FOUR SEVEN SIX
OH FIVE POINT ONE.
AND AUTHORITIES DIDN'T ANSWER
THAT'S WHERE THE EXEMPTION LINE
LET ME JUST AND I REITERATE MY
COMMITMENT THAT IF YOU DISAGREE
WITH OUR INTERPRETATION WE'LL
FIX IT TO MAKE SURE THIS BILL
DOES NOTHING MORE. THAN TO SAY
THAT THESE CENTERS THAT ARE IN
THE MIDDLE THE DOWN OUT THERE
AYE THAT GRAY AREA ARE NOT
FORCED TO SHUT DOWN. PULL THIS
BILL GOES INTO NAVY AUTHORIZED
SHOULD THEY HAVE OVERSIGHT
THAT'S MY CONCERN TO DO THE
OPPOSITION WHICH THIS WEEK. JUST
TO BRIEFLY.
CORRECT SOMETHING I HEARD IN
THE CURRENT LAW DOESN'T ALLOW
YOU TO SET. RESOURCE CENTERS AND
CONTIGUOUS COUNTIES WHAT IT
ALLOWS ITS ME A RESOURCE ONE
RESOURCE CENTER IN IN THE
CONTIGUOUS COUNTY NOT NOT
MULTIPLE AND SO WHAT AGAIN WHAT
THE STATE BOARD HAS SAID
ESSENTIALLY IS YOU HAVE A YEAR.
IF YOU'RE LOCATED OUTSIDE OF THE
DISTRICT TO SEEK AUTHORIZATION
FROM THE DISTRICT WHERE YOU'RE
SITTING.
AND SO THAT WAS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE ENOUGH TIME TO GO ALL
THE WAY THROUGH THE APPEAL
PROCESS IF NEEDED.
FOLKS NEED TO SEEK OUT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE THEY'RE
SITTING AND SEEK AUTHORIZATION
AND THAT WAS DONE.
THAT WOULD THAT THEY WERE GIVEN
A YEAR AND AND THAT WAS JAY LENO
ONE'S APPLY FOR A WAIVER SO THEY
DID.
SO YEAH THEY'RE OPERATING DOZENS
ON LIVE FOR WAIVERS.
DOESN'T THE SECOND IN A PLAGUE
OF THE SECOND.
TO DO THAT.
THEY HAVEN'T YET.
APPLIED FOR A SECOND WAY RIGHT
RIGHT WHICH SO WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE A SECOND THING RETURNED FOR
SO I'D THERE MAY BE SOME OTHER.
QUESTIONS HERE.
DETERMINE.
AND YOU KNOW JUST JUST IT.
.
JUST LOOKING AT ME.
THAT THE LANGUAGE HERE IS
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT I'M READING
IS DIFFERENT THAN WHAT I SEE.
WHAT I SEE IS REASONABLE?
AND IN TERMS OF THAT WHAT I READ
IS SOMETHING TOTALLY DIFFERENT
IN THAT'S HERE SO IT MAKES IT
VERY CONFUSING.
BECAUSE IT I MEAN TO ME IT
WOULD BE LOGICAL TO BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP. A CENTER IT IN THE SAME
COUNTY WHICH IS MAKES MORE SENSE
FOR PEOPLE IN THAT DISTRICT THAN
IT DOES TO ALL THESE OTHER
COUNTIES THAT TOUCH IT BECAUSE
THE METS. MORE DRIVING TIME AND
SO FORTH AND SO ON SO IT IS.
.
IT BUT IT DOESN'T SAY THAT HERE
THAT'S THE PROBLEM I HAVE WHEN I
READ THIS I'M KIND OF CONFUSED
AND NOT SURE WHAT WITH IN
DEALING WITH. VIRTUAL CHARTER
THAT HAVE NO SPACE WHERE THEY
CAN OPEN THESE THINGS ANYWHERE
IN THE STATE IN THE IN THE STATE
BECAUSE OF SAYS. YOU KNOW A A
BEING EXEMPT FROM EXISTING
GEOGRAPHICAL RESTRICTIONS COULD
BE YOU KNOW HAVING A SCHOOL IN
OREGON SOMEWHERE BECAUSE THOSE
GEOGRAPHICAL.
STRICT XIN SO IT DOESN'T SAY
WHAT I THINK YOU'RE INTENDING TO
SAY.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW TO FIX IT
IN TERMS OF THIS AT THIS TIME.
YOU KNOW BUT DOES.
IT IT'S BUT TO ME IT'S
REASONABLE THAT WOULD BE UP
WITHIN YOUR COUNTY BECAUSE IT'S
OBSCENE YOU CAN GET THERE FASTER
YOU KNOW AND IT'S AN AND THE
KIDS OF IT. AND I I'M REALLY
INTO MAKING SURE THAT.
WHATEVER WE DO IS CLOSE ENOUGH
SO THAT THERE'S SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR WHAT'S
HAPPENING THAT THOSE WHO
AUTHORIZED CHARTERS CAN VISIT IT
AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S DOING
WHAT SUPPOSED TO DO AND ALL
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE. SO SEEMS TO
ME IF IT'S IF IT'S IN THE SAME
COUNTY TO MAKE A LOT MORE SENSE.
BUT IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE OF
WHAT IS WRITTEN HERE AND THAT'S
WHAT I HAVE TO GO ON.
AND.
.
ANYWAY.
SO I I HAVE SOME DIFFICULTY WITH
I MEAN JUST OUT THE BILL'S
ADVOCATES HAVE DIFFICULTY WITH
IT.
AND NOT BEING ABLE TO FIX IT
AND I KNOW IT'S VERY CONFLICT
COMPLICATE WITH LOT OF THE
DISCUSSION THAT'S GOING ON.
.
BUT IT'S IT'S NOT CLEAR IN TERMS
WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S WRITTEN ON
STAFF THANK YOU SO I I DON'T
KNOW IF WE'RE GOING TO THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OF THE THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL. THE ISSUE
AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL I
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU IF YOU ARE
GOING TO DO I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
THE IMPRESSION YOU HAVE. AYE
SEPARATE SEPARATELY THERE ARE
RESTRICTIONS ON.
WHAT STUDENTS CAN ENROLL IN AND
I IN A NON COSTS ARE BASED ON A
CHARTER BUT IT'S LET'S BE CLEAR
THAT AGAIN I'M GOING TO ASK
THERE IS A THREAD ON THERE?
LISTEN THERE IS A PROCESS NOW.
ALSO I NEED TO GO IS THE COUNTY
IN OF THE COUNTY WHITE BENEFIT.
WELL I WANT EXCUSE ME THAT'LL BE
A COUNTY WIDE BENEFIT CHARTERS
A PROCESS NOW THAT CAN BE
EMPLOYED SHOULD THEY CHOOSE TO.
PP EXCUSE ME STUDENT CALL ON ONE.
EXCUSE ME EXCUSE ME. EXCUSE ME.
PLEASE.
SAY WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY.
I AM THE CHAIR.
I'M AND I WOULD JUST CLARIFY
THAT
EXISTS A PROCESS
NOW.
DONE WE DON'T NEED A NEW LAW.
DO IT.
YEAH ADDRESS STOCKBROKERS
QUESTIONS YOUR.
YES
THANK YOU
SO AYE SEPARATELY THERE ARE
LIMITATIONS ON ENROLLMENT SO I
STUDENT CAN ONLY ENROLL IN A NON
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER IN IN
THEIR OWN COUNTY. OR ANNA JASON
COUNTY SO WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT.
TAKING WAY GEOGRAPHICAL
RESTRICTIONS I GUESS IT'S TRUE
AS THE WAY THE BILL'S RIGHT NOW
IN THEORY THIS SHASTA BASED US
SCHOOL COULD OPEN A RESOURCE
CENTER IN SAN DIEGO WHERE YOU
COULDN'T ENROLL ANY STUDENTS
FROM SAN DIEGO OR ANYWHERE THERE
YOU CAN ONLY ENROLL THEM.
FROM THE AREAS THAT ON THE MAP
THAT'S WHY AND MAYBE THE
COMMITTEE DISMISSED THIS IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT'S WHY THE ANALYSIS
DOESN'T REALLY.
HOLD WATER BUT IF WE DISAGREE
ON THAT I WOULDN'T SAY AND I'M
STATE ON THE RECORD RIGHT NOW MY
INTENDED JUST TO HELP OUT FOLKS
I LIKE THE ONES WHO HAVE COME
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY. WHO ARE
GONNA BE OUT OF LUCK AND HAVE
THE RESOURCE CENTER SHUT DOWN?
AND IN MANY CASES HAVE THEIR
SCHOOL BECOME MORE VIRTUAL AND
HOT LESS VIRTUAL.
BECAUSE OF THIS COURT DECISION
THAT IS UP ENDED.
A LAW THEY RELIED.
THANK YOU.
I'M
ANY OTHER.
THANK YOU SO CHAIR.
TO THE AUTHOR OR TWO WITNESSES
CHIU.
I'M ACTUALLY LOOKING AT THE BILL
LANGUAGE AND IF YOU YOU SAID YOU
WERE GOING TO ADDRESS
THE CHAIRS QUESTION TO YOU OR
STATEMENT THAT THERE IS A
PROCESS.
I AM CURIOUS IF THERE IS A
HAS HAS ANYONE AVAIL THEMSELVES
TO THAT PROCESS AND IF NOT WHY.
ALL OF THAT ADDRESS THE
SPECIFICS OF THIS WHAT HE WHAT
HE SEEMED TO BE SAYING IS WHILE
YOU DON'T GO OUT AND GET
SEPARATE AUTHORIZATIONS.
FROM SEPARATE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
OR COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
FOR ALL OF THE RESOURCE CENTERS
YOU HAVE IN ADDITION TO THE
ORIGINAL AUTHORIZATION YOU HAVE
FOR THE ACTUAL SCHOOL. AND AYE
YES IN THEORY THAT CAN BE DONE I
THINK IT HAS BEEN BEEN DONE I
MISTER REISS PERHAPS CAN CORRECT
ME BUT I THINK WHAT THEOPPOSITION IS CONCERNED ABOUT IS
ACCOUNTABILITY ACTUALLY THAT
BALKANIZED ACCOUNTABILITY. NOW
SUDDENLY YOU OF MULTIPLE
AUTHORIZES WHO ARE PLAYING IN
THE OVERSIGHT ROLE.
FOR ONE SCHOOL BUT I'VE YOU
GUYS HAVE MORE SPECIFIC EXAMPLES
ALL OUT FOR YOU WELL I CAN SAY
THAT DOZENS OF SCHOOL.
SCHOOLS WHO HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
HAD NEEDING TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE APPELLATE
COURT DECISION.
HAVE SOUGHT TO VARYING DEGREES
BECAUSE IT WAS A IT WAS A
REQUIREMENT OF THE WAIVER BY THE
STATE BOARD. THAT THEY COME UP
WITH A.
TRANSITIONAL CONTINGENCY PLAN TO
COME INTO COMPLIANCE OVER THE
YEARS PERIOD. SOME OF THEM HAVE
SOUGHT THEIR FOR. A NEW CHARTER
SCHOOL AUTHORIZATIONS THROUGH
DISTRICTS AS WELL AS THROUGH
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION AS
MR O'DONNELL SUGGEST.
THAT HAS.
COME WITH MIXED RESULTS.
SOME HAVE BEEN MET WITH
RECEPTIVITY.
AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN MET WITH
PICKS
DREAM HOSTILITY.
IN FACT TOLD AT THE DOOR THAT
THEY WANTED NOTHING TO DO WITH
THEM AND THEY WOULD NOT EVEN
LOOK AT THEIR CHARTER PETITION
LET ALONE CONSIDERATE. SO.
WHILE IN THEORY IT'S A WONDERFUL
OPTION.
PRACTICAL APPLICATION IT HAS
MIXED RESULTS.
THE OTHER.
THE OTHER THING TO POINT OUT IS
THAT.
WITH THE DISTRICT AUTHORIZED
CHARTER SCHOOL.
SOMETIMES IT'S.
IT'S NOT.
FISCALLY POSSIBLE.
TO GO TO ANOTHER DISTRICT WHERE
MAYBE ONLY TWENTY OR THIRTY OR
FORTY OR FIFTY STUDENTS ARE
BEING SERVED. IN THAT PARTICULAR
AREA AND GET A NEW CHARTER
SCHOOL AUTHORIZED THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO SUSTAIN ITSELF. SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. PERHAPS
THE DISTANCE AWAY FROM THE
CURRENT AUTHORIZD CHARTER THAT
SERVING.
A FEW DOZEN STUDENTS AND. THAT
AS A SEPARATE CHARTER WOULD NOT
BE FINANCIALLY SUSTAINABLE BUT
YOU STILL NEED TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THOSE
STUDENTS AND YOU DO SO WITH THE
EXISTING CHARTER. WITH A
RESOURCE CENTER IN ADVANCE SO
ARE GOING AND AND THAT'S WHERE
YOU CAN HAVE THE BEST OF BOTH
WORLDS A DIFFERENT.
YES RICE.
YOU YOU.
WERE.
GIVING.
SORT OF THE BACKGROUND.
AND I WAS FOLLOWING YOU.
AND THEN I WAS IN THE AWKWARD
YOU LOSE IT WHEN TO LOSE NOW.
ATHLETIC. USUALLY FOR ME THE
MORE WE TALK ABOUT IT THE BETTER
YES IN THERE SOMEWHERE I FELL
INTO A HOLE AND I'M STILL IN IT
OF WIRELESS POINT OUT. WELL
GLORIA HOW CAN I HELP
WELL I THOUGHT I HEARD YOU SAY
THAT.
.
YOU AGREE THAT THE LAW. ALLOWS.
A BLENDED LEARNING SCHOOL.
I FOLLOWED YOU SEE YEAH YOU GOT
IT.
.
TO OPEN A RESOURCE CENTER.
IN.
COUNTY WORDS AUTHORIZE.
GOING TO JC CAN A COUNTY
ADJACENT TO WHERE IT'S
AUTHORIZED
WITHIN THE AUTHORIZING DISTRICT
DISTRICT.
IF THE INDUSTRY IN THE
AUTHORIZING DISHES BOUNDARIES
YES OKAY AND AND JASON COUNTY
OKAY BUT NOT IN THE REST OF THE
COUNTY. LOOK REALLY WHAT'S
MISTER THERE WITH ME ARGUED HERE
IS THAT WE SHOULD HAVE DISTRICTS
AUTHORIZE THE ENTIRE COUNTY.
NOT COUNTY'S AUTHORIZED THE
ENTIRE COUNTY. THAT'S THAT'S
WHERE THIS WILL ALSO GUIDE
ANYTHING AND I GET THAT WHY THE
ARGUMENT THAT.
THERE SHOULD BE AN APPLICATION
FOR COUNTY BENEFIT I GET THAT
I'M GONNA ASK A DIFFERENT
QUESTION THE LAST TO THE AUTHOR
TO EVER YOU WANT TO ANSWER IT.
I'M LOOKING JUST AT THE BILL
LANGUAGE NOW I READ THE ANALYSIS.
I LISTENED
I THOUGHT I KNEW WHAT IT WAS.
THAT I MIGHT BE THERE AND THEN I
THOUGHT I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING AT THE BILL
LANGUAGE AND I HEAR.
WHAT I SEE IN THE BILL LANGUAGE
IS DIFFERENT WHEN I HEARD WHAT I
HEARD TODAY CONSISTENTLY WAS THE
ABILITY TO OPEN A RESOURCE
CENTER IN A WAY THAT'S MORE
CONVENIENTLY LOCATED FOR
STUDENTS BILL TO GET TO ACCESS?
SEEMS REASONABLE WHEN I READ THE
BILL LANGUAGE ALL I SEE. IS THAT.
AN EXEMPTION TO ALLOW.
EXEMPTION FROM GEOGRAPHICAL
RESTRICTIONS THAT'S ALL I SEEN
THE BILL LANGUAGE
AND SO I DON'T SEE WHERE THE
BILL LANGUAGE MATCHES UP.
WITH THE THEMES THAT WE HURT DAY.
WELL I MEAN I I ALREADY ANSWERED
THAT MISTER THURMOND IN THAT
THERE'S.
YA SEPARATE SECTION OF THE CODE
THAT RESTRICTS.
ENROLLMENT AND SO.
THE.
YOU KNOW.
HAS IT IN THEORY YOU COULD THAT
HAVE A SATELLITE.
RESOURCE CENTER.
pPART OF THE STATE BUT. THE
STUDENTS THERE WOULDN'T WOULDN'T
BE ABLE TO ENROLL IN THE SCHOOL
SO IT WOULD MAKE ANY SENSE AND
YOU WOULDN'T SEE THAT.
ONCE AGAIN I'M PUTTING IT ON
THE RECORD THAT.
THE THING THAT YOU SAID SOUNDS
REASONABLE IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE. THERE'S NOT
SOME SINISTER SCHEME. REMOVE
RESTRICTIONS AND HAVE THE WHOLE
STATE BECOME VIRTUAL SCHOOLS NOT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN FACT THE
RESULT OF REJECTING THIS BILL IS
GOING TO BE THESE BLENDED
SCHOOLS HAVING TO BECOME MORE
VIRTUAL BECAUSE REMOVING. THE
ABILITY OF STUDENTS TO ACCESS
THE PHYSICAL SITE WHERE THEY DO
THINGS LIKE HAVE DIRECT
INTERACTION WITH TEACHERS GET
ACCESS TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES. PREMIERS HAVE A QUITE
PLACE TO DO HOMEWORK.
I DON'T WANT I DON'T WANT
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES TO GET
LAST.
OR MORE DISTANCE FROM THOSE WHO
SEEK TO HELP THEM.
BUT AS I READ THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL GRACE IS A HUGE CONCERN FOR
ME. AND THAT IT SEEMS TO SUGGEST
MANY CREATES AWAY TO CREATE MORE
DISTANCE BETWEEN.
SCHOOLS.
VIRTUAL SCHOOLS BLENDED SCHOOLS.
IT ACTUALLY DOES WHAT YOU SIX
DON'T WANT TO TO CREATE DISTANCE
FROM WHERE STUDENTS WILL BE
BECAUSE IT'S NOT BRICK AND
MORTAR AND THAT CREATES. AN
EXEMPTION WOULD THERE'S NO
GEOGRAPHIC BOUNDARY AND IT
CREATES DISTANCE BETWEEN. THE
AUTHORIZED IT WHICH COULD ALSO
BE A SUPPORTER.
TO THAT SCHOOL.
DUNST LOOKING AT THE BILL
LANGUAGE
AND IT SUGGESTS CREATING MORE
DISTANCE
STUDENTS WILL BE DESK DEPRIVE
THEM WHERE THEY GET HELP.
INCLUDING FROM THE AUTHORIZED
AND THAT'S
THAT'S WAS FOR.
THAT'S WHERE I'M HAVING TROUBLE
RIGHT.
YOUR CALL US RESPOND QUIT OUT IS
THAT IT IT'S IT'S THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
IF YOU HAVE A STUDENT WHO'S IN
THAT MIDDLE AREA OF THE GREY
THERE THAT'S GOING TO A RESOURCE
CENTER THAT'S IN THAT AREA
THAT'S CLOSE TO THEIR HOME.
WITHOUT TODAY'S BILL THAT
CENTER IS GONNA HAVE TO CLOSE
DOWN IF THEY DON'T WORK OUT AYE
SOME OTHER ARRANGEMENT CAN BE
VERY CHALLENGING AND OFTEN DRIVE
FURTHER MAYBE TO ONE OF THE
ORANGE AREAS OR TO THAT TO THE
READ THAT'S ACTUALLY FARTHER
FROM THEIR HOME AND THAT'S JUST
THE. TRUTH AND IF YOU YOU KNOW
IF YOU WANNA.
SAY YOU THINK OTHERWISE THAT'S
FINE BUT THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN IS HAPPENING.
WOULD YOU SHOW ME WHERE THE
LANGUAGES IN THE BILL.
THAT SAYS THIS ALLOWS US TO
CREATE RESOURCE CENTERS CLOSER
FOR STUDENTS I'M JUST QUOTING
THE LANGUAGE. THAT SAYS.
GIVE AN EXEMPTION FOR ANY
GEOGRAPHICAL RESTRICTIONS.
AND I DON'T SEE ANYTHING THAT
SUGGESTS.
CREATES.
RESOURCE CENTER AND MORE
PROXIMITY.
TO WHERE STUDENTS CAN BE HELPED.
I WANT TO BE HELPFUL I JUST
DON'T SEE IT IN THE LANGUAGE AND
I'M ASKING IF YOU CAN POINT OUT
TO ME.
ARCHER WERE BOUGHT OUT BY THE
LANGUAGE WE'VE BEEN REFERRING TO
THAT'S FOUR SEVEN SIX.
OH FIVE.
AND OUT ALLOW WHY. MY WITNESS TO
READ IT YET.
IF YOU HAVE A QUICK RESPONSE
OTHERWISE GONNA MOVE YOUR MISTER
STEINORTH QUICK RESPONSE WAS
THAT IT THAT EDUCATION CODE
FOURSOME SIX OH FIVE AND FOUR
SEVEN SIX
FIVE POINT
SAY. THAT A CHARTER SCHOOL MUST
LOCATE WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES OF
ITS AUTHORIZING.
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THAT THERE
ARE A FEW EXCEPTIONS
THAT ARE ALLOWED TO THAT ONE
EXCEPTION IS.
THAT A CHARTER SCHOOL MAY LOCATE
ONE SIDE WEEKLY LIVE IS A
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES BUT WITHIN
THE AUTHOR WITHIN THE
AUTHORIZING COUNTY UNDER A
COUPLE CONDITIONS.
THE OTHER EXCEPTION IS THAT A
CHARTER SCHOOL MAY ESTABLISH A
RESOURCE CENTER MEETING SPACE OR
SATELLITE FACILITY IN AN
ADJACENT COUNTY UNDER A COUPLE
CONDITIONS.
WE'RE SIMPLY SAYING WE'D LIKE.
ANOTHER EXEMPTION.
FROM THAT.
DISTRICT BOUNDARIES ARE QUICKLY
SHOWN.
FOR NON CLASHING BASS CHARTERS
THAT ARE PROVIDING THE STATE
MANDATED SERVICES THROUGH
RESOURCE CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY IN WHICH IT'S AUTHORIZED
PALESTINIAN TELL WOULD YOU WORD
IT BECAUSE IT'S NOT WRITTEN HERE.
HOW WOULD YOU WORD THAT EXCITES
BUT THE PROBLEM HERE IS THE
BILL'S VERY PLAYER
THE WORD NOT WITHSTANDING?
ANY OTHER LAW A CHARTER SCHOOL
WHICH ALL PUPILS ATTEND THE
CHARTER SCHOOL.
THROUGH NON CLASSROOM BASED
INSTRUCTION
SHALL NOT BE SUBJECT TO THE
GEOGRAPHICAL RESTRICTIONS AND
THAT'S IT IT'S IN THE BILL
MISTER STEINORTH. WELL I JUST
WANTED TO SAY I'M THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF DEBATE A LOT OF
DISCUSSION I UNDERSTAND AND I
TRUST MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY AT HIS WORD. THAT
HE'S GOING TO WORK WITH EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US.
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE INTENT OF WHAT THE MAP AND
WHAT HIS STATEMENTS ARE WILL
MATCH LANGUAGE THAT WE WILL HAVE
A CHANCE I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
THIS BILL SO WE CAN CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE ACHIEVE THE OUTCOMES
THAT WE'RE ALL. LOOKING FOR.
ALL SECOND.
OKAY.
YOU MAY CLOSE THE MOTION IS.
WELL IN A MOMENT TO PASS.
YOU MAY CLOSE DISCO.
THANK YOU ALL FOR THE.
SPIRITED CONVERSATION.
AYE YEAH YOU KNOW IT'S FUNNY
THE ARGUMENTS WE'VE HEARD HERE
ARE ALL IN THE CAN JUMP YOU. CAN
JUDGE OF THE STATE OF THIS COULD
HAPPEN THAT COULD HAPPEN BACK TO
THE MATTER IS WE'RE NOT
INTRODUCING ANYTHING NEW.
WE'RE SIMPLY TRYING TO RETURN.
FREE ANDERSON STATUS QUO BUT
WE'RE DOING LESS THAN THAT
BECAUSE OR SIMPLY GRANDFATHERING
IN THOSE FACILITIES THAT ARE
EXISTING NOW.
WE HAVE SOME DEBATE HERE OVER
THE STATUTORY LANGUAGE TO
COMMITTEE BROUGHT THIS TO OUR
ATTENTION WE OFFERED TO AMEND IT
TO THEIR SATISFACTION. AND THAT
OFFER IS STILL ON THE TABLE.
SO.
I ASKED YOU TAKE ME AT MY WORD
ON THAT AND THAT YOU GIVE ALL
THESE FACILITIES THAT SERVE SOME
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE KIDS.
AND THAT WERE CONSTRUCTED WITH
PUBLIC DOLLARS IN RELIANCE ARE
CUT DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
VERY OWN GUIDANCE GIVEN I CAN'T
A CHANCE TO CONTINUE THE GOOD
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE AND.
THANK YOU.
UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PROMOTION AGAIN IS TO PASS.
O'DONNELL NO O'DONNELL NO KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA MCCARTY.
STEINORTH STEINORTH AYE THURMOND.
THURMAN NO WEBER.
WEBER NOT VOTING.
HOUSE TO.
THE BILL HAS TWO VOTES.
SO WHAT WE HAVE.
WE GET A MOTION AND A AB TWENTY
TWELVE.
AB AB TWENTY TWELVE IS HOMAGE IS
MATURITIES INFORMS WHAT WERE.
AB TWENTY TWELVE IS.
.
BY MR MEDINA ITS FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY MISTER
THURMAN.
AND CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS.
DO PASSED.
O'DONNELL AYE AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KALRA.
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NO THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
WE.
IT HAS THREE ONE ISN'T IT IS A
IT IS ON CALL.
WE NEED MORE MEMBERS WHO WE NEED
YOU HAVE.
WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON CALL.
STONE TWENTY OF. AB TWENTY
ELEVEN.
NO.
KALRA.
TWENTY TWELVE DEFEAT AB TWENTY
TWELVE BY MR MEDINA.
KALRA.
KALRA CALLERS AND I.
TO.
THIS ONE.
TWENTY TWELVE
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED